Great stuff!
>> Good morning, everyone. How
this That's
So, Ibetter than I talk from
React asleep!  thought. thought
everyone another would still be
to with morning, we're going
going open up  she's and style
Sarrah Vesselov, to talk about
how aReact. UI - UX  Sarrah is
lead  and wasat Gitlab,
developer UI part of that,
senior sheNitro
She a  Mobile. at Mad a
solutions whowomen develop. and
girl [Applause].  serves and as
Sarrah!  director for  who from
code it Let's hear
some  So  Good had morning. I
tell,
SARRAH: early. for with probably
little  fonts and Snafus with
you cannotes, this so bear me a
bit. Thank as you coming the So,
my pretty from some title on
painful of personal experience.
based talk, it's start today
sharing that I experience with
you.wanted to by
My So, UI in 2015, I team.
senior worked product amain at
developer on a build  to
scaleable, role was maintainable
a which months CSS for concept
small vapour  essentially lot
worked but of The team  app of
us hadstart-up a on a proof real
architectures. lookedfirst  as
like a ah, well, writing done
our get had  snagged to ware. We
and begin to lot of was time
buzz and opportunity business
client. It exciting down to
quality
It decided an production we
code. an was in and build from
to one it app for scratch
practices best Just we were
going do for
there any started me. React.
trouble Up the until problem:
weren't where in thistime, is
styling React attake  and this
care  take the to me been happy
have changed now, all team had
styles - to This good. care of
all the CSS - they didn't care
styles -  looked of all the it
fact,as long as my ten-plus
sudden, and, in  years of All of
a nothing,  withdinosaur.styling
React. absolutely  meantin
applications meant a was it
gave that I was changed  And
this an Facebook because, that
2014, engineer at your a talk
in made talkshave CSS  a
everything. His the represented
case for putting
And really JS. thisoriginal
traditional NBC view changed
component-based  to more from
shift we  technicalures that way
architecture and in  we few
months the code were the next
styling relationship to thethe
way the view rest of base. So my
worst in the presentation became
- some of meant Every one
career. conversation was bully
into confrontation orbecame
every it other shame  a and the
to friends any ofend of side or
seeingcrazy? none ofthe error
their were  ways. At the sounds
familiar, it all, sounds us If
it more. This It was. sorry.
But we're really endhave would
tried not itchoices. didn't
imploded we have to team stuck
choices because this way. The
styling bad technology just
most of the had of was In
reality, if we problemmore we
The far  worked and with things
way it. theproblem. We us, made
theavoided approached  had had
havethan   right needed to in
could If we complicated
listening terrible  the we they
questions be. really other, been
asking  andto each has  lot A
ago. the whole mess. That years
was two local - a  a really
recent debate ischanged. The
hasn't. Thisarguments
So, did for  that   Googleago.
search I I the same about just
So years  made today CSS. talk
see two look being to thatwe
were having and a both I want
and today, the take of at sides
of can cons that argument, then
and look at that reallystyle
pros theeach way you  sides of
against bothdebate.broken,
gripes is CSS in React. So, know
with the Ilook at all want to
Starting  We no-no in
JavaScript. CSS. a Why are we
global  uses it's CSSdoingscope
and right?  bydependencies
default,overriding   CSS and it
in styles? side,  CSS
inheritance collision the
You're wrong on and at all make
style concerns look just
inevitable. looking at
separation of We separation of
right? a CSS concerns as a
technologies, andseparation of
and reallywhat each piece is
it'sdeadin CSS  JS,  andcauses
separation of   of components
linesthen cascade of course
doesn't of doing. And the and
with thousandsCSS so youdead
code work   this at scale, have
CSS isn't are JS. there equally
strong broken - code problem.
But gripes and  against
you use create CSS to toit.
JavaScript just don't know how
UsingCSSreinventing the
unnecessary.   is excessive
works andyou  we friend if your
is CSS on Why are from cascade
separate be wheel? should
The fine just CSS itsmark-up.
own. your course,  And, of know
how to use it. oh,
oops, use - your apologies
friend if sides cascade both to
styles The isit,there!  So
course, you know how  hack.
and, of inlineconcerns are a and
the  CSS side JS andhave pretty
serious the CSSside is  some
about what other  look at two
let'scategories,own  doing. So
now we've basic  theheard sides,
four can the  cons. I'm  into
options. You break down and its
styling pros each one with sets
of the basics. withgoing to
start
Naming intelligently. things out
methods
There style  eliminate are a lot
of to  is among threadthere.
Common allof themcollision
Standardisation specificity   by
modularity. Loguewithand
encouraging work  methods
CSS, In SASS, 2015, it. you name
that
Rules the - stands was for  BEM
has modifier. really
Everything block
everything. element  class - are
really, simple. should anever No
Elements styled.course, styles.
be directly  follow nesting of
conventions. Of religiously.your
must choose  And syntax naming
you the
component - and  block So in
this my frame a
It's have  component.example, I
my friend  Any entity. an  or
have no image, own. use
description their liveDOM node
in always never  my should is -
they friend meaning on node or
friend It
You would in  base. name, friend
block. anywhere elseyour code
class that  inside extra replace
are anits never  it. And
And
Modifiers to modifiers block,
blocks and just in  change  the
name that can be added
behaviour.  elements to modify
appearance for should only to
startone with,terms of structure
and  folderhere's I'm just
component component is
structure, a simple this means
you to it, by no general in is
telling very structure this is
thethink way do structure and do
personalised I  folder way that
you can from it. component to
project.well, and dosimple
project should   Here we've
thing component got the  it
structure. Eachfolder one do
and in the that each contains
the JS, CSS and testtwo files.
In this  presentational out
components. example,  our been
brokencomponents represents
two categories. The they folder
andcomponents havesimply
They're stateless,make   The
container components take props.
They are are benefits There
stateful. cetera. of API calls,
etapproach.concerns, a lot
reusability  toconcerned this
better get but You  separation
ofif get something you'reteam a
different type ofpresentational
projects,  is and you design can
be in other the The that  by
with. that components also the
worked on affectapp's without
concern it'sgoing to to BEM pros
logic. of in a lot methods
So there are standardisation
think  I and a general. for
building they'renatural fit
configuration, just using  no so
we'recomponents. There's cetera,
configure or set to compiler, et
nothing together. There's
straight CSS. and put up
Using again used  be over BEM
components, eachcomponent can
make
And  over and projects. and in
other namescollisions and single
class   impossible,
presentational  enginesthe
rendering   evaluate,  to - BEM
structure toeasier to that lends
so right is think itselfevaluate
CSS left, Ithe less there
perfectly render. is to faster
it going to
standards. But added can style
so every same linting the some
cons. conform to is things there
are that naming anyone it,things
to Let's for the face crazy
probably one of  this really
sounds hard. It's think  the
hardest we dotime do. It  I my
so something someone else name
doesn't of knows to   a living
butRickid most what architecture
out building CSSrigid Theis
figuring the BEM -- about. of
whatwhat I'm talking structure
ismakes and whatmakes it
structure ofdoesn't BEM at  it
work can write also   difficult
not think you to something to
weird,first. It takesnatural,
when  frustrating feels it
longer. Itfaster and be feel
natural, being  this  can wayand
order method. you're do
something intobuy-in in in
another  team  particular but
forced got get syntax system to
into thiscascade
You've to this the  for benefit
ofcandebate seen
Losingcon work.  the things
can be or as which cascade  the
pro used The depending things
side of when you fall on.bloated
or use drythat  a directly
hacked.  result in a overridden
and code base with styleare is
It's use there to  possible
theming for would say out BEM
methods  important but I and
there. is is far better but
somethingthat you'redashes that
you con, Theming  serious
something to It work and the a I
back toabout again, doing. may
not underscores befeels really,
And, goes   the ugly. when you
work it with themnaturally
reallywriting difficult think
things   come that's make
something or doesn't can a lot
next into that. to this at
turningslower.pre-processors.
We're So the I want look
helpful A  dry codeallows and of
write than CSS planefaster. name
a lot you CSSmix-ins,  you
operations,  to variables,   It
contains features  likeit.
SASS is one of think the
pre-processor - Ilanguages  bad
news the I'm extension about So
going tothatmost well-known
talk.  upon  thisSASS, and that
is onepre-processor, is syntax
touchthings. In this   here in
name to any need or still is
you I'mcomponent convention the
same. The  example, naming look
continuing to use the the friend
BEM more will forset.  is that
which itself here is component
difference   of to out The
instead having bring write
entirety,nestingeach class? Its
the readable usingassemble  to
ampersandvariables   each have
same class. We the up could
exactly I be in here and of ways
there are willoriginal to a lot
output our  CSS  dry witheven
further. in Again,has  as
nothing structure, example.the
folderapproaching each We're
separating really changed. a
still  longer we're component as
whole entity, instead no on
separating presentational and
but HTMLcomponent. components
CSS lives within the that and
container file  CSS components.
In this the ways. toSASS
individual have different style
example, outputting an canit a
ofstyle   one into However, you
do this whole  number I compile
that
You could actually sheet and
load So pros.  sheet instead. of
a lot pros
There are  to nesting.mix-ins,
the of lot ofpre-processors. you
a  power a lot grown In that
It has have dry SASSyour on.
features  of us can  dependent
think using gives general, you
really also up code quite I a
bit arepickthese features. know
a lot of them already real easy
to and CSS, up. If you in no
jumping  to much there's without
SASS. You overheadeach
presentation straightaway
working  with  can do it up,
first set  help. And is
modular.spectacular to a filed
component can beone orreally
Each SASSyour intointo CSS it
one sheet liveswithin that
exported so single to sheet that
forneed  component, lends the
itself  work team and are
project you There It's
So it to. your cons.
dependencies. some use
configuration in  need to add
SASS already what we project,
consideringyou will do to big
con with not really a weblayer.
pack  mind it more of keep in
can get out and other is one
very seen some Nesting I've devs
newcontrol very, things quickly.
to
They're  and  nestpossibly deep
hell!  in SASS  tenthemselves
straight  to outSASS. got that
like they you've can't figure
really how React be happened!
So with to careful said would
arguecomposition but Having
component that, I   general in
that the and need of Reactmix-in
nesting. bereduces the for  that
They building the bigshould You
should and not things.   be
small components do a the lot
those of So
The you need should need small.
you complicated. amount of
styling even be relatively  may
not  a lot Just name things. You
have right?wanta to refrain.of
things, seems to  don't  to do
It popular this. bethe really
styles. not about  Now are to
talkstandard inline
The and Inline I  and  styles
will get same  as that a  CSS
been time. JS, Iwant methods
long justback to that in about
have minute.  first twos goes a
we  talked inlinethe  for quite
2015, styles inyour But
Having CSS style further. to
even them idea of usingkind
seemed  entire application of
the crazy. So just like it
inline to sounds,they're
stylings inline  sameactual DOM
again, asCSS styles node. And, I
component, the simple not the
thing   attach
This and JS. to same frame will
getyour that.  is of the And
styles. example inline this
stirs R first example was the
got horrified when were team
that we in I've say, theCSS
folks on the brought to us 2015.
to
To this. we saw not most inline
styles. be fair, this is  how
people are using
Most are  is objects. more
handles   using style example.
Itdocument React native
It's much Moinit takenable that
than the first  also the Most
way  separate and component.the
style styling. will a take one
step import further place into
the  objects in and then that It
Does it sound familiar?of
should!  At  many  for thought
thethetime,  an   this?"  The
style You us was "Seriously?
like wantus tolaughable at the
seemed entire application app an
by styling subtitlevery thought
of  injecting because -
injecting style time, seemed
font  size, Theperspective of
laughable colour scaleable.
folks, at the time. From time
not the  the CSS thethis was
times in several changed
application   pallette of the
had How we were app.working on
the  fonts changes  to manage
likewere we for there inline
going need
Surely that with avertical
styles? was  and rhythm,  colour
disstressing moredo.  of
couldn't  subset Even it
supports awas learning what
palette. styles onlyyou  So
inline  CSS allows
We're going CSS. the to CSS. of
get actual toand JS on the other
hand  I generates to use all
power minute. CSSbecause it keep
a Ithat those inpositives know
saying  are some but we're
almost quite there there!
lacking and I think model mental
your
Inline styles are change a bit.
to really Inline its you to
them. as styles forces admit
componentreally entity. will
against see each that  ownof not
I
This was something it and.js was
did for me.  -- idea  CSSthat I
the and against CSS JS go had
but did I my of itup.practice,
inline on everything ﾣ  learned,
writing years hack else bestable
to  view andput component and my
was  really localise those my
its Using a tostyles. I as and
styles changed being able
component that. concern see the
in own see the value
specificity,  theleave in And
obviously,accidentally isway
styles are  inline trump card
right? There or no  that someone
is going to hanging  override
them unused stylesReactwith
React those around. If you to
will move to intend stick to
styles work.long-term to go
easier you native, yourlibrary
So,  It is going to be much
longer.  bit a cons list the is
over. So CSS to on a basic
accessthe big need depend
features, to   the and this time
was one of side at the arguments
fromadding these that CSS
library,  do that this? we were
would   we things Why CSS adoes
naturally.  using that If to
you're not to it's things
necessaryselectors, workarounds,
address programme JS  the you
media gives queries, out of all
of CSSchanges just  notwhich
global style You're would debate
cascade.the box. Again, make you
component  the side of the
dependinggoing to you're
cascade. Every to on,  lose
touched on the were able be
usingacross changes need to and
and the components. be - all the
--  go acrosswas I've
components. to all the the did
got to saythe it  difficult when
develop innot theDOM.  I most of
really names to my work in
looking class inspector, and,
you're   using it's you're
mapping when tell what
elements, difficult Even to know
lookingstiffare at.  you looking
what you're rest styles  at,
it's to the tell what you're at
in with because theyour jammed
of  outsidebasisthemselves to
enough, the  elements.
Interestingly  other code
reconfigure themselves
components  and inthese don't
lend in placing   use go inline.
because you're directly have to
to  styles
You would hand in order it every
single one by usegood. we found
eachsomewhere else. And another
where  thing that styles
interesting inline very be of
that performance was not be A
going to less has to pageful
performant  is stylethan tag
parsed single a loading itsheet.
and JS 2015, So is CSS hot In
fire. right now. was on  In
2015, there weren't  CSS
Modules, a lot libraries,
Radium,and of JS wereaside that
from CSS cons the and had
Many of Aphrodite just come out.
inline JS could - plaguing I
think quite  it's evolved a
think bit. I butgoing 2015 I'm
represent giant in so  that
So, style and they  libraries, a
leap forward aboutin CSS JS to
talk
today. componentscomponent. You
same friend our  here we have
So a be
Style together. by putting this
should There's component  way
we'refamiliar with this now.
difference in weren't the real
use actually toutilise this
literalscreate components
So, late    tagged tell me and
components. CSSimportingthat
normal Reactcomponents, as you
we're can able  see, from style
are  importing styles then we so
we're library, andaround
construct a wrapper to component
thatwrapper section a styles to
applies the  class So tag. So
mapped styles. way style.section
in the to those  difference ina
equals a big maps DOM with a
name that not it's styles.
It is generating you inline
actually that is handle inline,
it style sheet, actually sothen
a CSS at   And is that document.
head run styles. time, it your
name to the loading into the
classsection of the applyinghow
you folderthe  beand,  component
be So I touch  decision, should
that team structure your ever
will cases, would a you in most
say decided beforeI've  example,
component styles. In this it
actuallypiece, broken broken
that  down even we've each
further. constructed way down
we've just
Here, the  I'm is each piece
bringing of that render and then
my component. I'm building in
and Here, as entity, one I've
eachits separate That way, I
file. broken out can index build
use  into mycomponents own
themactually and other and again
areas these over and and
scaleability flexibility over
Lego allows more of in other
blocks,long-term. You This like
a bunch  really. can  to around
easily pieces smaller move those
components.construct larger them
think style So I components have
without  a  allow CSS and going
for  and inlot real CSS They
sheets, writeJS libraries
general do. you instead  to
mapping JavaScript style
context-shifting between
removing that of and it
practices by also CSS the
enforces the CSS. best and
between HTML independent they're
components, presentational
Because you're purely building
and  small reusable. And
single-use  class
Single-use there names makeclass
go!  make -naming names we with
presentationalcollision. You
your containers and easier your
no chance of  so out have
components,you're separating
from yourbasic logic.   has
actually
Style do components support can
really with Theremix-ins. SASS
so you nesting,  things of
variables, It are a loteven cool
features there. and native
support,  has mobile themed
as an JS approach and means
support.followed CSS choosing
some a Choosing  are cons. So
choiceframework, one choice.
another   so there
Glamour, style it's by modules,
CSS there Aphrodite, are many
components, ofthis andout entire
and at the  flavours CSS takes
JS  an there, endall of deck I
have a possible resource that
you to and list of I   the
another CSS which JS the  use
mind, somethingchoices you have.
And is it's yet library to
things library that think is to
keepto be inmight soquickly, a
because  needs  change  thing
today relying on that problem
hot new something it So, on. be
a later also entire the is
understoodto bythis case team.
complexity solid the And I think
a be made and forstyles
designers teams have a while
interduces. Many so CSS, be able
in implementing and design and
patternsutilises in  developer
might to this jump rightthere
difficultfeel comfortable
because it the JavaScript, so
much of be what is  others on
already in could for
depends!  team. use? It  Ianswer
So, is:
what should there
I  but think  know there. I
you're looking for the answer.
onereally aretoday, one really
out is no  There to choices
question it does depend. need a
lot of  by right Ithink you
start askingteam? the  on theof
what  questions. What mental a
model based is models on are
facts. It A about model is
belief not theknow know  users
think. Whatmisunderstandings  up
mentalperson's they  clear
understanding each users help
system. And or think can a
styling aproductive mental model
of having so  styling I person
sees that you really  and foster
can each conversations. think
good speak to ideaof how can
bit better a little theirview on
it help you in those
conversations.theacknowledge
to  I isalso important  skill
skill think it of mixturehave
differingimplementing levels on
a as  the team.  If there is
designers levels, I said, you
and a lot of not your clarity
can simplicity and  CSS may
JavaScript,really be comfortable
in then devs,  skilled
introducing of highly help
everyone stay a group
technologies iftogether. And,
you're pose or new a problem.
won't complexities of probably
that muchneed you to  What do
need to of actuallymaking the
industry you sure lot build?
Make  understand what latest you
There is a our tech is latest to
build. the pressure in whatever
be really know tempting the to
can framework, And it jump on
language,today. the rounds
latest technology.before So,
libraries and complex adding for
systemsusability, make styling
there'ssomething  as sure asand
build  you actually need.
Stamp out simply possible
possible. How do you as out
start restructure from there. --
simply your as
React
understanding notstructure help
project?that's  is will about -
you how  you want to your
project Forseparatelycomponents
determine rest the
Will container style your method
going to work Best   and the
live of styles? Is
presentational team. to global
components will access kept from
together? the for orhaving to
they becouple   Will you have
anticipate  need you are athat
somethingyou These so these
styling have?   of
considerations think about
things before jump into making
that toimportantly, is right
decision. more Even
environment. I think, create the
requirestechnology.   right to
Building things successfully
does morerequire than the right
environment. ingredients It
really are four think   the
First, that happen. I there
making extreme Taking costs.
positions at all on a subject
avoid dogma  andcreates
conversationsdefensiveness
before tension trust the don't
youpeople you're  harder if even
get started.  even is really
hard risks it's Taking
Build trust. and to do, it with.
doing  onchange. to
Think push back  and you you
needyou're embrace to instead,
the yousomething, Whenever  in
feel rememberyou will be friends
you lean many   is surprised at
what  the learn, and you how
vulnerable. Italong say going to
make  Lastly, be to way. need to
seeand  something, okaybenefit
understandyou don't don't builds
that you  for the honest in it.
Being understanding trust and
the opportunity for greater
everyone on the team. also And I
-  quotethink it isunderstanding
begin with to this to important
remember -  and I CSS love
having a thoughtful ofit help
build Whether do  is going to
you  SASS, or you'regreater
things. CSS, you CSS what and
using to understanding how very
JS, isbuilding and it use
important. Thank you.
[Applause].
>> Thank you so much, Sarrah. I
think I have just one question
for you. So you mentioned how to
style React components as a
divisive topic, and you
evaluated the - you evaluated
the pros and cons, but what if
you have to work with someone
who does not agree with you? How
do you not lose friends that
way!
>> Not everyone's going to be
your friend, right? At that
point, you have to agree to
disagree, but commit, so whether
you agree with that decision, or
the other team member agrees
with that decision, as long as
you all commit to making that
work and moving forward with it,
it's going to be just fine. It's
all going to work. It's the best
way.
>> Okay, so just, like first
acknowledge that not everyone
can be my friend?
>> Yes.
>> And then commit to my
decision.
>> Commit to that decision and
keep going with it because
you'lling going around and
around, refactoring, and it will
be a mess.
>> Thanks a lot, Sarrah.
>> Thank you. [Applause].
second talk the of small so the
is So we actually have change,
for a minutes. There break for
eight schedulingtrack a small
originalmoved  otheryou the was
so slot  cancelled,  talk will
be thiscatch so, if first  to
totally now, to want to go over
and that's therefine. that
minutes, talk, here stick  talk
yes, another eight Otherwise,we
next for  will have the
ready.
[Break].
>> Hello. So you know like
sometimes when big companies or
brands say something rely
ridiculous on social media or
something and people call it
this brand is having a PR
nightmare? So, for example, just
a few weeks ago, CTQ ran out of
chickens. So 900 of their stores
in Britain were forced to shut
down. It was as though the KFC
crisis on Twitter.
What did KFY make a giant pull
request and the - well, it
turned out PR nightmare meant
public relation nightmare, not a
pull request nightmare.
Otherwise, they should totally
tune in next to listen to the
next talk where we have
Catherine Meade teaching us not
how to have pull request
nightmares. Catherine works at
Sparkbox. She has a strong
passion for education, she
expense a lot - she spends her
free time volunteering and
teaching with girl development.
Her other hobbies include
reading, table top games and cat
jokes!
[Applause].
>> The first letter on this
repository link here is D. I
will share is it again. I
tweeted it
[Applause].   out. My name is
I'm a full stack developer. I
use her/she pronouns. We have
about 40 people working at
Sparkbox. I spend most of my
time working on an enterprise
level design system you can ask
me about later. Today, I'm going
to share with you a few tools
and techniques to make your pull
requests more effective and more
collaborative. Because of time,
I hope to do a quick summary of
a few tools, and you can Google
them later after the
event. Most are not GitHub
exclusive. I know there is at
least one GitHub person.
Hopefully, like you still find
something even if GitHub is not
your main technology. I should
share a bit about context and
how Supportingbox does code
reviews.
We store nearly all of our code
on GitHub. We used shared
repositories dedicated to
whatever engagement we are
working on. Developers have -
whenever developers have new
code to add to the project, they
ask another developer for code
review of the
pull request. I've come up with
six rules that Sparkbox adheres
to. I came up with these rules.
So, I do not represent the
thoughts and ideas of
my employer. Rule number one is
no-one merges their own
close. One developer is writing
emerging piece for a website.
Last year, we had a client who
wanted an additional full-time
developer for the project but
they would be the only developer
on that project. We offered
instead two developers at half
time. Having a reviewer is that
important to us. The second rule
is never push directly to
master. It is the easiest way to
break everything. Requiring code
review reinforces the quality
that comes value as the company.
Third rule:  if you're working
with UI, get a design review. We
have a position called a
front-end designer. Every
project we design, this special
designer will often write for an
end code so they may use some
CSS but not every company has
designers who knows how to code,
and nor should they. If you're
working on copy, get a
copy review. This is usually the
project manager or the client
themselves. We have an
integrated development process,
so the clients usually have
access to the repositories we're
working on. Rule number 5 is
never, ever push directly to
master. Again, unless you
messed up. Which, if you did,
find a Buddy to pair with, which
leads me to rule number of 6,
these rules are more like
guidelines.
If you follow these six rules it
ensures that we follow the basic
Sparkbox creed which is working
together for a web bit right. If
every piece of code has at least
two people contributing to it,
we often catch mistakes before
they happen. All of that is
context for about what I'm about
to talk about. It may be
different for you in your
company; it's just how we like
to work. I'm not telling you how
you should do code
reviews. Some challenges of
collaboration are getting a PR
from a non-coder, or or a PR
review from someone in a
different time zone. It's not
that easy. Working with
developers who may be only doing
reviews on your project
or working with people who are
assigned directly to PR review
and nothing else. So, how do we
improve these things? So I'm
going to give you six steps, I
think. I guess I like the number
6!  Tip number 1:  write good
stories. Two, ensure good pull
requests. We have to write good
issues. At Sparkbox,ee use
Trello to organise engagements,
usually with something like Scrm
which involves creating stories
which is a GitHub issue
representing a bite-sized chunk
of work. Stories should include
the requirements of the work,
and potentially a solution if
you have one in mind. A story or
issue doesn't need to be overly
complicated but it should be
easy to understand. A
well-written story makes for
clear requirements when it comes
time to do a PR, and this leads
you to my very first
recommendation:  the only one
GitHub exclusive but I'm sure
there's one similar on the other
technologies. For reference in
the photo, this is my co-worker
Austin who is a project manager
explaining that this footer is
not great so maybe we can use
some of the other colours
instead. So GitHub issue and
GitHub issue templates and PR
templates allow you to add a
markdown file to the root
directory to outline the issue
process. I will share this link
again in a minute. This is an
issue template. Here is my
markdown. It is included
directly in my project. In
addition to adding the template
file to the root of your
template, you can add a GitHub
directory. PR templates work in
the same way but have a
different file name and they
come up with you do a PR instead
of an issue. So here is the
issue template on GitHub. When I
click the new issue button, the
text field pop lays with the
contents of the template file
and the example files are stored
in the repo I linked at the
begin. I will link it again, I
think.  If you want to take a
closer look. Talk with your
project team to decide what you
should put into a template. Mine
is just an example. It is a very
flat example. A checklist is
nice. There is that link again.
I will give you about 30
seconds. Tip number 2 is to get
the basics right. A good way to
frustrate your pull request
reviewer is to send them
something with absolutely
no context. You could respond in
kind. These are
real PRs. But but a few extra
minutes to write a thoughtful PR
description can go a long way
towards easing the work of the
reviewer. We try to include a
quick summary of the work being
done, usually matching your
commit
descriptions. Link to any GitHub
issues or stories, especially if
you're using something like
sudden hub, Giraffe or Agile. A
link or screen shot of the
original design work if you're
working in UI. I love screen
shots, so they don't have to
open up zeppelin every time I'm
looking at something. Step by
step instructions including how
to run the lint or how to run
the tests, how to navigate to
any new work, how specifically
your new work is meant to
function. So here's that PR
example again. My other
co-worker, Bryan, he has hit a
number of these tips. They
should be written in the context
of the developer reviewing the
work. For example, a PR to a
developer who is only doing
review or QA may look completely
different to the one who wrote
the build process. All right.
Next strip:  enhance your pull
requests about gif. This is my
favourite gif because the cat
and coding, my name is Cat and
I'm a coder, so it's me. I hope
you like that joke. It's my own
one!  So what if a gif can be
more than a quick laugh? They're
awesome for showing functional,
transitions, hover effects,
animations, so pretty much any
visual aspect of your work. We
are a front-end shop, can you
tell!  They're good for getting
a signed review of
an animation for someone running
a site not locally. There is the
link.
Recordit is a screen casting
service and gives you a hosting
link. The CMS that the foundry
is built upon is a big skill to
set up. It may take a full day,
especially if it is for a
designer or project manager who
is trying to review one or two
lines of code or content. By
including a gif, you may give
the necessary context and allow
everyone to feel confident in
what they're approving. This is
a gif I made of some
functionality. Here's the link
to record it again. It doesn't
currently support HTPPS. It
means as you know, it can't be
embedded directly into a PR on
GitHub. It can still be sent as
a Slack link or as an email or
whatever. An alternative, I
recently discovered
gifox.
Hosting on GitHub gives you the
full security of your
repository, so you're not
violating your security
policies. It
does cost $5. This
one is really off. It is
including in Setapp, and I think
this one only works on Mac but
there are a lot of different
tools out there. It is the
thought that counts. Right. The
next one is enhancing your pull
requests with video. An
important aspect of a
complicated PR is the ability to
walk someone through your code.
The current devs are often
distributed or remote. We work
in different time zone.
Sometimes, it's nearly
impossible to schedule the 30
minutes to step through your PR.
Here's
the tool. It's GoVideo.
This used to be called Viewed
It. They changed it right after
I wrote my talk, so I had to
change it!  GoVideo is a Chrome
extension. Not everyone is a fan
of chrome -- hello,
Mozilla!
GoVideo let's people score their
screen and voice all at once. We
used a video like this on
engagement where the main
reviewer - me - was not
dedicated to the project
full-time. Because I was not
available for stand-ups, I
didn't have a direct hand in
building the website, and I
wasn't familiar with the changes
being reviewed. The dev had to
change every - GoVideo is my
favourite way to start a code
review. Hopefully, it works. I
keep meaning to rerecord this.
But people tell me that the
awkwardness is endearing. So
just go with
it!  Can you hear that? You
can't
hear that. Oh.
There's an audio cable. I should
have told you, huh!  [Laughter].
It is like, yeah. All right.
[Video]:  this is Go Video. It
records my entire screen plus a
little me down not corn year. I
think it's super friendly for
doing video walk throughs of
pull requests. Here you can see
that I'm on a pull request and I
can go into my file changes, I
can look at the code, I can
explain this haskell 3M to
Sparkbox home page. It hopefully
fixes an issue. I hope you like
it. Please merge it. Obviously,
I did merge it, because this is
me. And then, when you are done
recording your video, you can go
on to a screen. One shows up
like this. You can see that you
can change your
title like ...
you had try it some
time. You can change your
thumbnail, stroke through
contents, and, when you're done,
you get a link right here. And
that link is HTPPS, so you can
embed it directly into your pull
request, and whoever wants to
review your code gets a nice
friendly walk-through, and that
doesn't matter about time zones
over anything
like that.
>>
Good. Thanks. That's really
encouraging. [Applause].  So
here's the link again. Depending
on the size of your PR, a
walk-through video only adds
about five or ten minutes total
to our set-up time but it can
potentially save the 30 to 60
minutes to explain your PR via
Slack or email or scheduling a
Zoom meeting. This is useful in
pairing developers who have
different schedules, who are
remote, or not as familiar on
the engagement you're working
on.  Two more tips:  give
valuable feedback. Skitch is a
free app from Everynote. It's
the - evernote. It's loved by
Sparkbox for everything from
full-page decoms to quick design
edit to making memes of your
co-workers. I use it daily.
Here's an example. It provides
elegant mark-up tools for boxes,
arrows, highlighting any
unnecessary changes. You can
take a screen shot and have
it.
Shift command 4 on a Mac!  Here
are some real-world examples. I
pulled these directly out of
Slack. This is the best joke on
my slide, and it's not even
mine!  You can Google Skitch. It
works well in the opposite
direction of Recordit. It's an
easy way for designers to work
with developers, make this
bigger, reduce the spates here,
delete this link. It provides
visual feedback for visual
thinkers. Right. Last one. One
last way to make your PRs
friendlier is to be friendly.
Via GitHub comments, it's no way
to collaborate. We know that
communication is difficult in
text which is why we invented
the emoji. Bryan who wrote the
awesome PR earlier also wrote an
article about this topic called
stop giving depressing code
reviews. The idea is to give as
much positive code feedback as
you do correction. It is hard if
you just go through and see the
negative, and you don't offer
any positive comments. You can
do it. So, this is a picture of
Bryan. He knows I'm including
it!  And instead of really going
to this topic, I'm going to read
you this quote:
"Giving positive feedback is an
easy habit to adopt. You're
already reading through the
lines of code looking for
issues. It doesn't take much
time to throw in a nice or a
looks great. You see something
awesome, say it. So the link to
the full article is there, but a
few positive comments make a
huge difference" whether you're
speaking with designers,
developers, other team
contributes, clients, which are
really important. Yes, be nice.
And that's what I have.
Hopefully, at least one of these
tools can make the PR experience
more accessible for your entire
team and not just the
developers. With a healthy dose
of empathy, we can improve the
way our co-workers and us write,
and make better websites. If you
want to hear more about Sparkbox
as the design system I'm
building, come and find me. I
have decals up here at the front
desk, and that's it. [Applause].
>> I'm going to make everyone on
board to watch this talk!  That
was really, really good. One
question:  if you were to make a
large feature and you know it's
>> I'm going to make everyone on
board togoing to be big, at what
point do you open up a PR? What
do you think of work in
progress?
>> I love work-in-progress PRs.
The minute I have a commit, I
hope a PR so people can see my
work in progress. We have a
work-in progress label we throw
on there. Iive whip comments as
well. If I that I can a change
to a large body of work, I'm
going to write a blog post about
this stuff in the next few
months. If I make changes to
what people have reviewed, I
like to use a web commit and
squish them down at the end but
it makes it easy to track with
changes.
>> I absolutely agree. I'm also
a work-in-progress. A round of
applause for Catherine!
[Applause].  I think we're a
little bit early, so we have a
good 20-minute break. You can
the washroom, refreshments, or
what-not. We will be back here
at
.
>> Does anyone know who Harry
Houdini was the?
Who Harry Houdini was? He was a
Hawk fairan-born American
magician, noted for his
sensational escape acts. His
first attracted - he first
attracted notice as Harry
Handcuffed Houdini on a tour of
Europe where he challenged
police forces to keep him locked
up. Soon he extended his
repertoire to include
chains, from skyscrapers,
straight impacts under quart, is
the traitjakets under water.
What does that have to do with
the next talk? Absolutely
nothing!
Aside from the fact that it is
about CSS Houdini, and I do not
know anything about it, so I'm
rambling and reading
Wikipedia
article. Our next speaker is
hailing from New Delhi in India.
Arun Michael Dsouza is currently
working at Pushup on various
related technology and products.
He's an open-source enthusiast
and has released several
utilities and libraries for
Angular JS, SASS, et cetera.
Let's hear everyone talk about
CSS Houdini!  [Applause].
>> Thank you so much. I hope I'm
audible to everyone? Okay, so,
let's start. So, yes, about me:
my name is Arun. I've come all
the way from New Delhi in India.
I work as a software engineer by
profession. Mostly work with web
technologies, full stack
JavaScript, exact. I'm an
open-source enthusiast, released
several projects, and, you
know, other projects including
node projects, some Angular
projects, SASS, CSS, and all
that stuff.
I'm currently working at an ad
technical company out of New
Delhi, helping web publishers
optimise their revenues through
advanced testing, as well as
demand optimisation. If you want
to know more about us, you can
check out our
website. So, about Houdini. What
is it, and why is it so
important to talk about?
Before we understand what
Houdini is, we need to
understand the history behind
it, which led to the creation of
Houdini. Of course, as
developers, how does that help
us? I must mention that this is
going to be a bit of a technical
talk, so we will be seeing a lot
of code here. But before we get,
I want to know how many guys
have heard about Houdini or
maybe have experimented with
Houdini before? Okay. A few
people. That's great. You guys
might be wondering why I'm
talking about CSS in a
JavaScript conference, right? It
doesn't make any sense. If you
look at it, Houdini is not just
about CSS or writing better UI,
it is more about its connection
with JavaScript that makes
extending and developing not
just CSS but the complete
experience, and we will get to
it. First, let's travel back to
1994 when the W3C was formed.
More and more people are getting
involved with the World Wide
Web, and as they did, they
started bringing in new ideas,
suggestions and feedback. And
within a year or two, JavaScript
and CSS were released. The web
seemed to be growing at an
extremely rapid pace, and the
feedback cycle in place, there
was the need to keep the process
stable. So the W3C was
performed. Its job s to to
ensure that the web was built on
open standards. A lot of things
happened between 1995 to 2007.
The DOM was introduced. Ajax
came into play, and made
possible the development of
truly asynchronous applications,
and, of course, proper web 2.0.
Development started awaiting
their own solutions for common
problems, you know, in the form
of small tools and libraries,
made the famous library by John,
and then in 2010, Sharpe
introduced the idea of ...
levels. The whole game was
shifting and backwards
compatibility has been a huge
deal for us, so keeping that in
mind, developers starting using
and developing levels. As the
web grew further, there was sort
of a feeling of dissatisfaction
or a disconnect between the
community on how these web
standard committees were
creating and prioritising new
features. So, that's what led to
the creation of the
ostensible web manifesto. It
aims at creating this feedback -
virtues feedback cycle with
developers having the ability to
experiment and Polyfill
standards so they can test
implementation and gain insight
out of it. This movement started
by some of the most notable
members of the community, Alex
Russell, Bryan Carlisle, and
many other people.
And for the first couple of
years, the standard bodies have
been worked really hard on
working on projects, providing
early access to features,
building transpilers, and in
general, giving developers the
freedom to build and to build
new proposals and
specifications. And obviously,
in order to do this,
environments need to understand
the - developers need to
understand the underlying magic
of the underlying browser
features, because if you look at
it, most of the web is high
level, and it's extremely hard
to Polyfill or test new features
out. And that's why the
ostensible web manifesto also
argues that the standard bodies
should also expose and explain
the underlying platform
features, or the low-level
capabilities of the platform.
This obviously leads to quicker
feedback by the community and
new APIs and features, and
quicker bug fixes, improvements,
and overall streamlining of the
standardisation process. Now,
taking this further, what if we
were to Polyfill a new script
feature? Can we do that? Of
course we can, right. How many
have been using the latest
browser features since Year 6
came out? Gentlemen, exactly. A
lot of people. That's how
flexible things have become.
Instead of waiting for browser
vendors to implement you in
features, developers can make
and experiment with the latest
features. But what if you were
to Polyfill may be a new CSS
layout, or maybe a new fill
type? Can we do that? Well, not
really, because producers don't
understand how to extend to CSS.
I mean, we cannot simply define
a new display, or a new fill
type because all unknown values
are discarded by the CSS engine.
That's the main problem. So
where is the underlying CSS
magic? It's all here in front of
us. In order to fix this
disconnect, between the
extensible web guidelines and
the ability of CSS itself, W3C
have formed this sort of a joint
task-force, and this task-force
is codenamed
Houdini. It's named after one of
the most magicians of all time,
Mr Harry Houdini.
The aim is to expose the
rendering engine internals to
developers so that they can
extend it and create better user
experiences. So Houdini will
help in explaining and exposing
the magic of layout and styling
done by the CSS engine, so we
will be able to hook into the
processes in the rendering
pipeline, and be able to do all
sorts of things - create custom
layouts, define new paint and
fill types, whatever. Basically,
an extension of CSS it will be a
JavaScript, which is
amazing.
So, so Houdini has started
working on these new drafts
which include a parser API, a
layout API, and a few other APIs
that expose the rendering engine
internals. So let's cover them
one by one. But before we begin,
I should let you guys now that
many of the things I will be
sharing are in very early
stages, so the syntax might
change. The APS might get
change, you know? But
nonetheless, let's set started
and she what Houdini
has.
First is the ... yeah. First is
the properties and values of the
API. So, this particular API
extends the CSS variable spec
which obviously allows us to
create custom variables, and it
extends it and allows us to
create custom typed properties,
so like you can define a type in
CSS now, define a type in CSS
values. This also provides us
the ability to have like I say a
type. We can have, we can
specify initial values to the
CSS variables, and we can define
the behaviour. So all CSS
variables inherit by default, so
this might be come in handy in
order to disable this particular
behaviour. So, let's see what
the API looks
like. So, we have this
registered property function.
And we are using it to define a
new type of property called BG
colour, and I'm providing a type
here which is of colour. And
with an initial value of black,
and the inheritance parameters
option
which is - so, having a type
here is something new. Now, we
are talking about typed CSS
values. This obviously prevents
invalid property value
declarations, and so with a
particular type defined, we
always make sure that only the
value of a required type is used
by the custom property,
otherwise it throws an error. By
default, syntax which is the
type that can support any type
of value, but with the type
defined, such as in this case,
where I'm defining the type of
colour, the initial value option
becomes a requirement, so that's
why I'm providing an initial
value. So, let's look at a
complete example. So we use the
same BG colour of property of
the type colour with the value
of black. We're using it to set
the background colour of the
think class, using the standard
functions. It is pretty simple,
right? Overriding the default
values is pretty
straightforward, so in this
case, the background would be
coloured back, so you can simply
overriding it by redeclaring
your custom property. Now the
property will be - now the
background will be coloured
green. I think we noticed that
all registered properties are
bound to the root scope, so
overriding a customs value
property like this will only
have its effect on the current
element scope which is pink. If
you were to access the BG colour
property, it would still give
you the
value black. What if a non-value
like this string over here?
Since we got this property
registered with the type of
colour, and we have a default
value set to it value black.
What if a  which is black, the
CSS engine set up, and it
applies the background colour of
black to the class, so, this
becomes extremely using in cases
where you would want to resort
to back values for your custom
properties, and, of course, this
prevents any inconsistencies in
your UI which
is great. The syntax string
supports the following types. We
can have colours, we can have
numbers, percentages, URLs,
images, and a few other types.
We can view the list over here.
Next up is the time OM, so we've
been talking about typed values
over here.
This is what gives the ability
to give type CSS
values. So the typed CSS object
model gives us the ability to
convert value strings, the CSS
value strings into meaningful
JavaScript-type presentations,
so we have a specific API for
this which we can have typed
representations using
JavaScript. So the title, the
rendering engine, what which
particular types of values are
to be manipulated so does not
involve any sort of extra
parting of value strings in the
case of the - parsing, so this
offers significant performance
improvement. And it also
provides us this new class
called the CSS style value
class, so it also has a number
of subclasses. Which can be used
for defining all sorts of type
values, so we can have length
values, we can have transform
values, position, and a few
other types of
values. It also exposes style
map, so style map is basically
an interface which helps in
setting and getting CSS values.
So we can use - access the style
map and use the set method if we
want to set a new property value
here, like in this case, I'm
turning the height property to
100 pixels.
And we can use the same - we can
use the "get" method to get the
height back which is returned as
a subclass, obviously, as a
style value class, which is a
simple CSS class. There is this
open-source type OM available.
You can play with it if you want
to, get a feeling of how it's
supposed to work. Again, this is
just a proof-of-concept, so for
experimentation only. I will get
to the browser support for the
APS. Allows to hook into the
processes in the pipeline and
extending those processes to
apply our own  custom CSS so
this is where the fun
part is. This is what it looks
like. We have different
processes in the CSS engine, and
we have different worklets
attached to it. Each are at the
various point in the rendering
pipeline. You can see that we
have a separate worklet for the
paint stage, and a separate
worklet for the layout
stage, and so on. They are
called for any of the process of
the rendering engine, and
worklets are meant to be threat
agnostic which meansstage, and
so on. They are called for any
of the process of the they're
not intended to run on a
particular thread, so the
rendering engine can choose to
run them wherever it wants,
which it can be a separate
worklet thread. They run in sync
with the rendering engine, but
they are completely independent
on the main thread, so that's
the best
part. So this is how you would
register a worklet. In this case
where we're hoping in the paint
part. So this is how you stage,
and when defining the worklet,
we give it a name, and a
JavaScript class. This is where
all the magic happens inside
this JavaScript class.
Let's see how this magic
actually works at the paint
stage of the rendering pipeline.
So this is what the paint stage
does. It's responsible for a
painting background of the
content, and highlight of the
box. Based on its size and
style. So, during this stage,
the paint API will allow us to
create custom fills for our
elements. Inform an image which
we can use in the background
image property, something like
this. So, here we are applying a
custom-filled, using the paint
function provided by the API.
The first things first. We need
to hook into the paint stage of
the rendering pipeline, so what
do we need for that? Worklet,
right? So we define the paint
worklet. This example is
actually taken from the Google
developers' website, so they are
planning to ship the Houdini
paint API with the Chrome 65
some day next week is the
release date. So we can see
that, we have a paint
worklet, called checkerboard,
and we use it to paint in div,
so we attached the checkerboard
paint to its property. This is
the
worklet code. We have the
registered paint function which
we are using to paint our div.
This is like a standard function
used in the paint worklet, so we
get access to these threeworklet
code. We have the registered
paint function which we are
using to paint our div.
arguments in paint function
which is basically the
context, the geom is the metric
which returns the height of the
element, and the properties are
the style map properties we want
to access inside
our worklet.
Using this be paint function, we
create the checkerboard with the
three colours defined, which are
red, green, and blue. If you
have some experience with
canvas, then this might look
familiar. Here, we're using the
context to apply the fill, so
it's quite
the same. This is what the
output looks like. It is a
checkerboard fill made of
specified colours. I know it is
very simple example, but it
still tries to demonstrate how
easy it is to extend
the paint, paint process in the
rendering
pipeline, and the paint worklet
will be called every time and a
screen resize operation happens,
so, the button is redrawn on
demand and kept intact. This is
completely normal because every
time a fill happens, it is
calculated on the elements cut
in size which is generated
during the layout stage.
Additionally, we can use custom
properties in our paint worklet.
This is where the properties
arguments comes in. And the
properties arguments returns the
style maps, so we use the type
here to get the custom
properties from inside the
worklet. As of now in Chrome,
these properties are mostly, the
style map is mostly a wraparound
strings which is why you need to
convert it to a string over
here. Going forward, it will
change as soon as we have table
support for type OM. The input
function is required to fetch
the required custom properties
on any other properties that we
need to use in the
worklet.
>> Paint can be used anyway, but
these are two simple examples.
Multiple coloured, backgrounds,
the material design ripple
effect, so that what is of
benefit here is that using a
paint worklet, this sort of
effect becomes pretty simple to
make, so you don't need inject
extra DOM nodes here in this
case, and it's pretty simple to
use it. You can use a full list
of examples over here.
Obviously, you can use it to
Polyfill any of the proposed
fill types that the browser
currently does
not support. Next up is the
layout API. The layout API gives
you see the layout worklet which
we can hook into the rendering
pipeline to recreate our own
display types.
So, first let's understand what
the layout stage does. So, it is
responsible for generating the
and positioning fragments from
the box stream, so a lot was
there. Let's see what each of
these mean. The box tree shows
how the document structure looks
like, and what sort of elements
are there in the structure, and
this structure, and this is the
structure that the API operates
on, and let's us arrange all the
elements together. And each of
these elements can have multiple
fragments. As we can see,
fragments are like the tiniest
bits in the whole box tree, and
they're created for each of the
pseudo elements. In this case,
we have a fragment for the first
letter pseudo element, the first
line pseudo element, which is
provided by the black outline.
Now, the latout API gives us the
ability to create our own
display types with respect to
this particular box structure.
This is what the broader picture
looks
like. We have the parent element
applying the layout on and the
child elements further
containing the child fragments.
So the access to the child
elements is important here
because obviously we need to
arrange the elements and the
fragments within them, to
generate our custom layout. So
let's look at the worklet
now.
This is what the class looks
like. So we have a few started
functions. Properties help
stretching the property values
of the current element like you
saw in the paint worklet, for
example. Children input
properties gives the property
values of the child elements,
and the child play function
let's us define how the children
elements are to be displayed,
whether they are to be inline,
blockified, whatever. Then we
have two generator functions.
The first one is in sizes and
the second one is
layout. The intrinsic sizes
function allows us to figure out
what the max or min size of a
block is. So that we place our
elements accordingly and don't
waste any space available
because they're the specified
amount of space available for us
to do our layouts within the
parent. And the layout method
actually defines how the
elements are to be arranged by a
custom layout.
So, we create a constraint space
here which is basically the
space available for us to do our
layout. And, within the parent,
and, we position our fragments,
and it's all the block sizes to
finish up the arrangement of
the blocks.
So this example is taken from
the official blocks.
The example here talks about
stacking the elements on top of
each other which are inside the
parent. You can't really play
with it at the moment. It is
API, none of the browsers have
got it implemented. But it seems
extremely promising, I mean,
imagine writing a performant
layout without any JavaScript
packs. It's going to be awesome,
right? Now let's talk about the
an makes worklet. So animation
worklet allows us to create
highly performant scroll or
input-based animations - you
know, things like sticky
headers, parallax effect, and
all that. All of this is done
off the main thread. Because
we're using a worklet here, this
offers us significant
performance. No janky scroll
effect, I guess. Animations
running inside the worklet also
exposes the animation interface
from the web animations API
which means the worklet data can
be accessed on the main thread
using any of the animation's
APIs before now, let's look at
an example of a
scroll-based
header. This is the structure of
the document. We have a header
element, and an avatar element.
So, these elements based on the
scroll position, so I just
scroll down the element that
will animate and get fixed to
the top, and the header element
will lose its transparency. So
it also includes a worklet
module inclusion call. As you
can see here, this is a promise,
and inside the promise we attach
the key frame effects, so these
key frame effects are provided
by the animations API, and we
attach these to each of the
elements that we want to
animate. In this case, we are
passing an area of effects
attached with each element,
so we want to the avatar element
to scale down and the header
element to loose its
transparency. -- to lose its
transparency. Each of these
effects are available in our
worklet. We also create a new
scroll timeline on the scrolling
container which is the parent
container, which listens for the
scroll events, and it has an end
and start offset. So this is the
worklet class. It contains our
constructor where we define our
easing function. Then Geneva an
animate process.the animate --
then we have an animate process.
This gives the current scroll
position in document. And it
also gives us this group of
effects which are to be applied
on the specified elements. So we
said the scroll position on the
- which is the current time, and
the scroll timeline, and we
adjust the time of the effects
passed to us that gives us the
ability to control the timeline
of our key frames.
So this is how it would look.
You can see that, as we scroll,
the targeted elements are being
animated as expected. The best
part is all of this happens off
our main thread. This can
provide us some really high
performance benefits. Especially
things with that are parallax
effects. This is a demo created
by Sirma, so that team put
together a small Polyfill for
the animation worklet, and this
Polyfill is being used by an
example listed on their
repository. You can view the
entire example
over there. There are are two
more elements left which are
fuzzy at the moment. Even the
specs don't have too much
information about them to cover.
One is the parser API and the
other is the foreign metrics API
but we will still look into it,
and see where each of these APIs
can potentially
offer us. So the first one is
the parser API. As the name
suggests it will allow us to
parse CSS rules, or CSS rules
typed into interpretations. So
string-based based rules
representations, and it will
also have utilities to parse
entire style sheets, rule sets,
and all
those things. It's still like in
the early stages, so I can't say
much about it. The last one is
the font metrics API, so this
will provide basic font metrics,
or the font intended for our
information.
So, the two methods specified in
the spec, so there is this thing
called measure element method
which basically takes in an
element, and returns a font
metrics object, and we have a
measured text method which takes
in a DOM string and a style map
and returns a fonts metric
object which basically is
supposed to store information
regarding the width, height, the
boundary box baseline, and all
of that of the element. So this
will allow us to measure our
text actual elements and the
orientation, and allow us to do
some really cool things like
creating some interesting
effects, maybe.
So this was more of a brief
introduction to the Houdini
APIs. The main question is can
we use Houdini today? And most
of you might have guessed it:
the answer is no. But it's
coming soon. So this is what the
current situation looks like.
The Chrome team is definitely
push it hard to ship the new
APIs. You can experiment with
the properties and values API
and the typed OM which is
available behind the experiments
web features flag, so you can go
to Chrome flags, and turn the
flag on. As far as I know, I
think it is available in stable
chrome as well. Again, behind
the same flag. A fully
functional paint API like I said
is to be released with Chrome
65, some time around next week.
So that is a good sign. Clearly,
no signals to implement the font
metrics API or the parser API by
any of the vendors. Few other
browsers also seem to be
catching up - well, kind of - so
we might see some of the API
being implemented in a few of
the browsers. Not really sure
about the timeline, but be sure
to check
out
ishoudiniready.com.
With that being said, Houdini
will cover us capabilities to
extend rendering engines and
come up with really amazing
tools and patterns that will
facilitate the development of
truly rich web experiences. And
I'm really looking forward to
it. That's it from this side.
Thank you. [Applause].
>> Thank you so much, everybody,
for giving us a glimpse into the
CSS future. And that was a  very
informative and you covered
everything. I wrote down three
questions, and you can answer
them as you go, so I got
nothing, I'm sorry. Sorry to
disappoint!  However, I do have
good news. It's food
time. We're pretty on time, so
we have a full hour for food.
And you know how yesterday, I
said that the swag was only
yesterday, the as on Zo-on swag.
It is still upstairs, the same
place as yesterday. Today, from
12 to 3
PM. See you back at
one o'clock..
.
. is test.this another caption
is
.
This a
. caption
.
. .
This is a test. This is another
Unfortunately, yes, this is
another.
.
test. This is another
This is a test.
room?
I you
>> Hello. lucky Metro of
Berliners in the a your Yeah? If
you don't already have  pass,
here's day,because Michael over
youuntil 20 So, if hereused.
Metro pass has that would be
which hasn't used valid a March
heBerlin   from Michael, it free
the want get a go andthere!
Second Metro pass,  guy over
panel are speaker announcement:
today, we  going to have a  with
- Idon't have the list of
later  people -
Dan -  Sarah, I'm  with Anna,
audience, from are saying this
but memory. We youtaking
questions from the go on so, if
the site
if you're able so asking
slito.com upon, and be   andgood
and voted you will moderated and
they will to to make questions,
get  be might theyanswered at
questions,
the panel.
Slido.com  specs and yet, then
we standards web andtalks about
have thethat aren't in the
speakers fromliterally modules
importing event no future. This
talk isQuantum months   three
different. We haveleft, When
Firefox  headlines out a making
Firefox Quantum. it was came
cojsconf. talkago, and about
right, centre. Today
Perrier welcoming intalking have
Jean-Yves me We've  about the
story. Joinwe to
JEAN-YVES: Thank  excited
Jean-Yves.everybody.  Hello,
really you. talk I'm to be and
about here,fast, how hadMozilla
are  browsersQuantum   use
Firefox making will and I of how
as an example browser are
vendors modifying also the21st
are things the that Most ofthe
browser I'm to cope with say
century.browsers to  aboutvalid
of other taking the  for a lot
of Firefox but I'm example
Mozilla  Quantum. So,  atI'mthe
part of Jean-Yves Perrier,
outreach developer the story So
account. starts and I computer a
have a Twitter  with aworks. the
thelittle bit howcomputer, there
isand  So at core of   a
processor, over evolved have
processors quickly, very years,
the 1980s, 1970s,somethingevery
of the   was initially, in that
there saying Moore's last
century, the Law basically
called was which two or years,
three your computer as twice
fast as  becomes previously your
which veryprogrammes and later,
making years wasnothing,
convenient for people in  three
do browsersparticular because or
twice youfast. It and, is two
lunch. free browser as is like a
of
Lately, doubling decade really
their not the second speed any
are people century, areseeing
this 21st  processorsmore each
that bit a little is still two
or threethe years. It but, in
fact, it truemore in processors,
for  high  endfor no  we're
matter doesn'tthe because really
on the  web Most of run only a
on point run where we such
processor. want atime, web to
latest, device to the high-end
and the   you want it the
powerful willprocessor, it's not
the mostprocessors battery  the
So minutes. and else  just last
five have found a byanddifferent
way  it'shaving more free no to
increase parallel, is power, so
and  is there more their
processing in cores, here  power
difference the now calculation
have are that The cores lunch.
these make programmes themselves
to adapt to of use
to available. At the same
browsersyears,was over we want
time, for do were  has changed
the if you so at a the
beginning, displaying it 2005,
just in browsers,toyou document,
and even, box,
It is  images and making
developer.  put a few round
top-notch the what What wetoday.
a want ed more  the corner or on
case any were the nothave 60 run
at frames  to is to per with
transparency this running to
second; videos all  HDrotations,
want  with you effects,more tan
this and  virtual needmeans all
your  you onyou want to headset
which run fact, perbecause if
reality frames that, in   60have
a second, not to you headset
want withperat leastvirtual
reality   frames you need motion
not 100 sickness, if 80, achieve
There were  adapt. second in
order to to to hadthis,thethis.
In order  mostly in  cope and
with browserif 1990, the the
even  the end of 1990, designs
in the 1980s, over evolved
beginning ofyears, it ismodern
they've the   run the the this
same not is aboutarchitecture So
that can browser  what web. you
story todayapplication telling
and  websiteorder to  doing in
vendors are your without make
even do faster you having to
3, anything.  Firefox  for
course,launched robot. Of robot
The browser agent. We friendly
looks this it a decade,over the
next lit bituser it a   clunky.
Is still the adjunct that we
want to inhave on  doingbrowser
is a modern browser question the
web. The is what it adoes  2018?
howespecially  The and is work,
browser first part web quite
important is a understand what
to  you
So this changesunderstand are
engine?  that thehappening.
rendering so a little bit your
is downloading  is Thepages.
first thing browser the the
JavaScript, it HTML, the Each
requests on web, and gets just
files, HTML an parser, the CSS
into HTML pass all of this
engine at whole process the the
the DOM  of nodes,starts
generates of it DOMnodes. CSS
youloading the
With Every time parser the DOM
modify  not up. again -  CSS
first but what  followsgo in the
style the engine  and The thing
to and the rendering the applied
isthe style engine. andengine
takesapplied CSS  are yet It
rules themjust boxes. defined
what apply to each of the
doesn't rules that set of but
When you it the match are each
add DOM. defines whatimages, the
you  so the this,know element of
media, have  size of all the and
can theyou the videos, images,
youdefining when  the size  of
the is and, the which awill
videos, have layout have this,
you it  a  face  pagethat is
each of thebecause they  where
on you the layers, have several
be displayed butand of boxes.
You layers, on top inside the
other, be can is each don't know
yet whatis  So thisnext  The
paint. which layer is winning.
the the each of  on step is
texture to apply will - this is
that texture layers texture
text. some From  inthis, or the
then, you in is background the
video,is texture is awhich
image, your  just  define
visible. This to go to are you
have  then pixels And last the
the and next screen. and step,
the the composite, through
modify page onyou go yearseach
time  youoptimised DOM,  For
have to  thisprocess again. only
redesigning oryears, already and
withdrawing by the  part
browsers havechange   this  you
part of are when the pages that
is wholeactually modified this
the DOM and important not and
the page. But big really the
element.
Mostly,
I properlilogicallisation.wanted
especially tonew -  a   know to
First,we've created
parallelisation. isparts little
replacing improve  Rust been by
C++ in   bill by crib the
language has of Firefox this
make this, we tothis language,
and the - designed
writing thethreads wanted
executed course or be codes
multiple can  with on fewer and
so that easier C++ much, much to
of to than contributing
A lot even areas are on. and
most peoplepeopleprogrammers,
you the code, test new  if good
are really can also get
algorithms,
for programmers who are less
experienced. and we We created
an experimental browser called
patches Zero. It is rein in
Rust. It has algorithm that
takes
parallelism and allows us to
check
and these algorithms are working
really well. It has no
significant UI.
It is not a real browser. It's
an idea to test if the ideas we
have are good or not. Finally,
and this is the most important
part, servo can break the web.
The web is a complex piece, and
there are a lot of special cases
with special CSS properties, and
so on, and to test the
algorithm, you don't want to
have to write the engine in all
the detail first. You want first
to validate that, in the good
case, in the easy case, you get
the speed improvements that you
were - that you wanted to have.
So we did this servo, and we
developed a lot of things
on it.
At the same time, we wanted to
solve several other problems, so
Firefox had a stability problem
we noticed over the last few
years, it had a lot of crashes,
and we were wondering why. It
has the old theme, so like the
robots that were just looking
old, by just having an old
theme, when the UI in OSes have
been proved, it feels slow, and
there is there were a lot of
cases where, in fact, the user
interface was freezing - it's
called UI young. Finally, we
wanted to have the new
algorithm. So we
launched a project called
Quantum, at the beginning of
last year, and we decided we
wanted to make a equal leap -- a
quantum leap in
performance.Quantum leap -- a
quantum leap in performance. I
want first to thank my colleague
Lynn Clark who has drawn this
amazing drawing, I'm unable to
make any drawings that looks
readable by anybody, so she's
doing a lot of these drawings.
She's writing blog posts,
explaining how browsers are
working. There will be a link
later that allows you to have
more information. So the first
things that we have decided to
do is to change our style
engine. So the style
engineengine, as I said, takes
the different CSS
properties, look at the
selectors, at the specification,
and, in fact, for each of the
boxes, define, okay, this
property with this value applies
to this one. For example, the
background colour of the text
colour, the font, and so on.
This is something that has to be
done to each and every box, so
this is at first sight something
that can be used easily with the
parallelisation.
So we tried it in Rust, on
Stylo. Basically, we had several
processes, several threads, that
makes part of the tree and makes
the calculation, and of course,
it's not that easy because first
you don't have one thread or one
process per element on the page
because there are sometimes
several thousand of them, so you
have to give chunk of the pages
to each of the processes, so
that means that some of these
processes are just either at
some point because there is
nothing happening, finishing
work while others may be
extremely busy. So there is a
big complex algorithm here that
allows a different thread,
different processes still to
work from the other when they
are idle. With this, we created
and we validated that the new
way of doing styling in the
browser is, in fact, much, much
more efficient. But that was
only the first step, because
this is in servo, in the
experimental browser. We needed
to sort out the detail and to
integrate this into the real
browser. And integrating a new
style engine in a browser, it's
a little bit like doing heart
surgery, but with a person that
is still conscious. You want
your browser to continue to
work, you don't want suddenly to
have no new release for one
year, two years, while you put
all the wires together. So we
took the styles of Quantum with
the parallelism, the rule, and
the cache from - the
style-sharing cache from Chrome.
Sometimes, it - a lot of nodes
have the same ancestors and the
same values, so it works pretty
well, and, in fact, it wasn't
working that well any more
because lately, with all the
pseudo classes and so on, it
became more complex, and there
are less of these elements that
are - that were cached. So we
modified the style-sharing cache
in order for it to work again.
And then we just transplanted
Stilo into the browser, and this
happened last November in
Firefox 57 and we got for this
part a very, very large
improvement in speed. So Stylo
is the first transfer from
servo. It's not the stirs part
of Rust inside the browser and
solving a problem called
embarrassingly parallel prop. By
definition, style engine is
doing something that can be
massively parallelised. Of
course, when the page is simple,
you see little improvement. When
the page is very complex, you
see a lot of
improvement. The browser has
another challenge:
each time you click somewhere on
the browser, there is an event
handler going on firing and
executing some code. You want to
be sure if you want to have 60
frames per second or 120 frames
per second that all that is
happening on the main thread,
and especially these handlers
happening, is no more than 16
milliseconds or eight
milliseconds, or 120 frames per
second. That means that you have
to have go out of the main
thread as soon as possible
because while you're on the main
thread, you cannot harm the next
event, so the next event, when
you're scrolling a page W3C, or
when you are clicking and so on.
Initially, browser had
everything in the main thread,
and little by little over the
years, they start to take things
out, so first of them is a video
they are encoding happening now
most of the time on the graphic
card itself. There was a plug-in
also at this stage, kind of as a
worker and several others. What
is quite interesting is we have
another piece of computer power
on the browser that is
a GPU.
The GPU is designed for games,
is designed for the operating
system when you have a lot of
calculations to do on a lot of
data. The same operation on a
very large amount of data. And
it's very, very efficient for
this kind of thing. It is very
efficient for gaming. On the
browser, we have this kind of
operation. One of them is a
compositing, the last bit of the
calculation where you have all
the layers, and you have to
define which ones are visible
enough. It's the same operation
a lot of the time on a lot of
data. We decided in 2016, we do
offload the composition to the
GPU, and we did it. At the same
time, a little bit later, in
fact, we noticed that the
crashes just increased. We had a
lot of crashes. In fact, it
wasn't the browser itself that
was buggy, it was the drivers
that were buggy, so the crashes
were mostly happening on
windows, and, for example, Mac
has had very few crashes because
there are far less types of
drivers and graphic cards. So we
decided last year to solve the
crashes by having the
GPU, the graphic drivers loading
a different process, so the
process crash, the browser
detected the crash, it
restarted, and then it works
without using the GPU for this
part. So you don't have all the
speed improvement of the GPU but
you don't have the crashes,
either. That's a way we had to
mitigate the bugs in graphics
drivers. So the come positioner
was the first part - the
compositor was the part that
went to the GPU. The painting is
to take a texture and apply it
to a surface, colour ra - we
want to do the same. This is a
project called web-runner - not
yet finished, it's in process.
This is the ultimate goal. I
don't know when it will be
finished. If you ask manage,
they say soon, and the
developers say a couple of
years. It is somewhere in
between!
don't send it to the GPU, we can
remove it from the main thread
so we have what we call off-main
thread painting. This has been
done in Firefox 58 which went
out in January, so basically we
create a set of instructions
that is policed, that is
assigned to the layers, and then
we send it to another process
that is ratarized which is the
actual painting operation, and
uses its own process on the GPU.
That way, as soon as the
ratarization is not on the main
thread. We remove the
bottleneck. It is not as perfect
as having everything on the GPU,
but it's no more the problem. So
this landed in Firefox 58, and
there is an improvement coming
the next version in two weeks
where we discovered that we
don't need to recalculate it
each time.  It's simple. We have
Heweristic in place so we don't
have to calculate the whole of
the display list each
time. We have mostly seen
replacement of the PCs, the
browser. In fact, if you want to
have browsers that are as
efficient that feel quick,
responsive, you need to consider
it as a system as a whole
because, yes, you can have a
very efficient-style engine but
maybe the bottleneck is
somewhere else. So we changed a
way to do development, and to
prioritise the development in
Mozilla by having the triage,
privatise, and we applied this,
and we still apply this to fight
freeze in the UI. There is a
collection of 30 block pass
variation that is explain the
changes that happen all over the
place. It's going in a lot of
details, and he coins the name
"death by a million cuts". We
found bugs where we had to fix
ten bugs, and suddenly, we get
back a lot of them. Each of the
bugs was shaving one millisecond
here or there, but no
significant difference, but
together, they were giving a lot
of differences. One of the
things that we change is the way
we were doing. It is not
specific to Firefox at all and
it has been pioneered by Apple,
and it is called
checkerboarding. When you scroll
on your screen with a mouse or
with the finger, you never want
to scroll to stop. But
sometimes, it goes too quick,
and you don't have the time to
calculate what you present to
the screen, so you present a
default value and people,
instead of being confused,
scroll less quickly. The data
appears, the images appear, and,
initially, it was a
checkerboard, which is why it is
called checkerboarding. The
overall speed is not better, but
the feeling is completely
different. Another big things
we've changed is IPC. It say
known for a long time that, when
you communicate with a disk, it
takes a lot of time, and you
don't want to do this on the
hard - main thread. It is the
same when you communicate with
another process, especially if
it is a synchronous
communication, you don't want to
do this on the main thread. We
filed synchronous communication
and we wanted to have as much
synchronous communication. This
is where we did a lot of - there
were two people working for six
months on the
cookies. Because cookies were
needed a lot of synchronous
communication. They wrote the
cookies mechanism in Firefox,
and, in fact, it was 25 per cent
of our blocking on interprocess
communication, and, on big
websites, when it was fixed,
like Facebook is making several
- writing several times per
second to the cookies store, in
this website, like Twitter, or
Facebook, we were able to win in
the order of the second in the
time we made to display the
page. There were other offenders
like plugins but they're gone
today. Or the traditional
extension on Firefox and - often
does that, so we had to decide
to stop having
that.
There are plenty other things
that we have done. For example,
we have changed some algorithm.
They are still efficient but
they were already efficient,
but, in fact, sometimes they
were not making good use of the
cache, so we keep an algorithm
with the same complexity, but
that works better with the
cache, for example, and
suddenly, you have an
improvement of your performance
on complex pages that are the
same complexity of the
algorithm. Also, the garbage
collection, the parts that take
back the memory has been
changed. Instead of having to do
a complete sweep, or we can now
do an incremental sweep, so we
take a bit of the memory, and we
start because we only have a few
milliseconds, and we continue
later, so that means the memory
grows a little bit but when the
browser is idle, it goes back to
normal. At the same time, we
notice that memories
that is used towards the end
very quickly and so on is the
one that is usually released
very quickly, and what you have
done, I don't know, two hours
before, usually, you will keep
it until you cross the browser.
So we also have changed, these
kinds of things.
The last thing is we tried to
remove all timers in the
interface. Timers are really,
really bad. At first sign, first
look, it looks very nice because
you deal with the execution
later, but, in fact, you don't
control when the execution will
happen, and when the timer will
file. Not only will it fire on
the main thread, but maybe it is
a moment that is important for
something else. You have no
control. In fact, the web
platform in this can be used on
the website. We have redressed
idle callbacks saying fire this
or do this when the main thread
is free. We also did things like
throttling background tabs, so,
if it is in the back, it is less
important, but if there is
mutesic playing in the back, you
don't want it
stop, so we are defensive here,
and we progress with
experimentation. Finally, we
designed our user interface.
So the feeling of the user
interface is something
really important. The look has
to look modern. It doesn't
change the indeed but the
perception of the speed. Every
animation is happening on the
GPU, through the CSS. We had in
the previous interface animation
done in JavaScript, and they
were causing a good deal of the
- so that's really important
that animation, not in
JavaScript on the main thread.
We changed a bit the structure
of the user interface so it's
quicker for the user to find
elements. It is not quicker in
speed proper but it is quicker
for the user. And with all these
things together, we have now a
new engine. And it looks still a
nice robot but it looks much
more modern. And it's not
finished. In fact, Quantum was
released in November but already
the next two versions of the
browser had more improvements,
so web renderer is coming at
some point. We have other ideas
to improve things, and, in
general, the browser is still
evolving. It is not the end.
It's a new beginning because it
is the first time we have now
this power of having a massive
parliamentism on a browser. I
want to thank you for listening.
Also, you can help by installing
Firefox, by reporting problems,
especially when your application
is slower that Firefox than
another browser.
This interests us because it is
difficult to have real live
data. Each time we do a commit,
there are 2,000 hours of tests
going on on a farm of computers.
But it is tests.@not real-life
things. If you file a big and
say you can give help by
reproducing it, an engineer will
be very happy. Spread the word.
We want as many people to use as
many browsers as possible -
Firefox if possible too -
because competition is good,
because that's the way we
improve speed, and Firefox is
the way to stay in form. Thank
you. [Applause].
>> Thank you very much. That was
very interesting. I have so many
questions. Shall we start with
the easy one? How are you?
>> I'm fine!
>> So, you mentioned the
composition being offloaded to
the GPU but the benefit is not
universal because the windows
machines seem to crash more
because there are more different
drivers. You also mentioned
composition being - painting
wanting to be moved to the GPU
as well. Will it also suffer
from the same?
>> Yes.
>> Can I then derive from that
and say Firefox Quantum runs
better on Mac than a windows
machine?
>> No, it's a bit more complex.
Mac is an ecosystem which is
easier because there are fewer
drivers, but the hope and the
reality is drivers are getting
better and better because we
file drugs to the driver
vendors. Yes, all machines,
especially for paint will never
have web render working, but
little by little, this problem
will go away.
>> Thank you. [Applause].
So I didn't have the list of
speakers for the panel - I do
have now:
dress dress dress, Sean Larkin,
Anna Henningsen, and Dan Abramov
at the panel later. If you have
questions that you want answers
to, please go to
slido.com with the event code
JSCONF and ask a question. We
will be back in
eight minutes.
[Break].
So you can see a new house
already before it is actually
being built. Or you can make a
really cool small games on your
browser, on your website
integrated it with all
the
native, environment things that
you have, and you can make them
work with each other which is
really cool. You can also use it
to enhance your info graphics,
or to make your data more
readable with enhancing it with
the third dimension, so you can
also use animation time and the
third dimension to show
something you would like to do
with your data. I think it is
pretty interesting, and you
should definitely think about
how to use it. Most developers
that would like to start with
especially web VR have been
coming to me and asking me how
do I get started with 3D? Why is
it so hard to get started for
these people? This is what I
would like to talk to you about
today. I would really love that
you come out of this talk and
you have this little tool box
with things you have heard
before, and you feel more
motivated to start trying it,
because at first, you will be
overwhelmed by all the new
terminologies you're going to
encounter. Not only do you have
now things to learn, but you're
also going to be a movie screen
designer; you're going to be a
narrator; you're going to have
to learn to do UX in 3D, you're
going to learn about 3D
modelling, how to light a scene
properly, et cetera, et cetera.
That's a lot of things to
learn.
I would like to talk to you
first about the physics of life.
So, here you see - the physics
of light. This is a simple
scene. We have this apartment.
We see a computer standing on
the desk. We have a chair, we
have a window, and, outside, we
have the sun which is primarily
the source of light which makes
us see everything. But how does
it actually
work? Every light source is
emitting electromagnetic rays.
As soon as these rays are hid
hitting an object, they're going
to interact with that object.
Either the object is absorbing
all the light - in that case, a
lot of energy is being produced
- or parts of the ray of the sun
are going to be bouncing after
and reflecting a different
surfaces until that light energy
is
used up. I already said that the
electromagnetic waves consist of
different frequencies, so that
means different frequencies are
different colours. If one
frequency is absorbed, the other
two frequencies are going to hit
our eye, the retina of our eye,
therefore creating this colour
in our eyes, and we can
see it.
Different materials react very
differently, which I'm going to
talk about the differences
afterwards. But there are three
major things, as I said already:
absorption, reflection, and
transmission of light. We can
see this here a little bit more
graphically. Imagine you have a
perfect mirror which it is not
possible, even if you polish
your surface very well, you're
never going to have it, but
theoretically, a perfect mirror
will reflect all the light rays
uniformly. This we call specular
reflection. Then we have diffuse
material like cloth, wood, and
other things, that are not so
much reflective, so it's going
to take the rays and bounce them
back in a very chaotic
way. And you have propagated
light, so, if you have glass or
water, the light is not only
going to reflect, it's also
going to transmit through the
solid. It creates these really
cool effects. This is not
everything that defines in the
material, but as we can see in
this illustration, these three
components make a lot of our
real-life materials, and it's
never just one component
that is there in one material.
For example, if you imagine you
have a wooden floor, that is not
polished, the rays of light are
going to bounce back
chaotically. If you put a polish
or finish on, it will be shiny
from specific angles. That is
what I really want you to think
about when you get started with
3D because that's what a lot of
people get wrong or don't think
about because, why would you?
How do we now translate this
into computer graphics? I would
like to go a few centuries back
when the first cameras were
appearing called pinhole
cameras. You have a
light-sensitive film on the back
of a box with a little hole
inside. Only runway of light per
angle is allowed to pass through
that hole. It reads then the
colour on that spot of
the film.
- it creates then the colour of
that spot on the film. We're
also using this technique in the
render technique called
raytracing, and that's what I'm
going to talk about. However, if
you imagine again the sun, it's
not only shooting one ray at a
time, it's like a really big
energy source shooting down all
these billions and billions of
rays at the same time. Most of
these rays are never going to
hit our eye. They're never going
to hit our camera or whatever
specific spot we want to look
at. So what computer graphics
are doing is they use a
technique called backwards
raytracing, so we are tracing
the rays, but instead of going
from the light source, we are
going from our camera through
the pixel that we want to trace,
and we shoot the ray into the
scene, and we look at the first
object that we are going to hit,
the closest one. From there, we
want to see if this one object
is in shadow. Or if it is
in light. So, if the object is
actually lit, we're going to use
the colour of the material that
is defined at that space. in
light. So, if the object is
Basically multiplying it,
simplify that, multiplying it
with the colour of the light,
the intensity of the light. If
the object is in shadow, we're
just going to use black for now
as for shadow. This is very
simplified. Now, I also talked
about these other things that
are called like
transmission, and reflection, so
how are we handling this in
raytracing?
Imagine we want to see if we
have a transparent material,
like glass, we would like to see
what can we see through that
glass, and what is reflected on
the surface of that glass? So,
on the impact point, we have to
calculate the different rays
that we are going to trace. One
of those rays is going to be
reflection ray, and one of them
is going to be the refraction
ray. It's going to be, yeah, not
very nice the names are so
close!  And from there, from
these rays, we're going to do
another check if they are
hitting the next object, so, if
the reflection ray is hitting
this red sphere, it's going to
be red at that point, but the
refraction rays hitting the
green sphere, so we have to
calculate together if we want to
have the pixel there red or
green. From the impact point of
the secondary rays, we are going
to trace towards the sun, and
see if these points are in light
or
not. I want you to have a moment
to look at
this.
Did everybody get it?
[Laughter].
Can you come here and explain it
to me? Because this is how I
feel about my own code after two
weeks of not looking at
it!
What you're looking at is the
basic implementation of a
raytracing engine that can do
reflection and refraction with
geometry primitives of spheres,
and I think - and this is a
common challenge among people
who do computer graphics, is how
to make the most compact
raytracing engine that can be
fit on a business card. So this
actually compiles, and I think
that's pretty ghoul. Let's take
it apart a little bit. What we
want to do is define our
geometry primitives. And for
now, we're going to talk about
the sphere. The sphere is one of
the most easy shapes to
calculate at intersection. For
that, we need a centre, a
radius, and we want to have
material, because as I explained
before, that's the most
interesting part. And we're
going to make another algorithm
that will calculate our
intersection from that. If we
are successful, we're going to
return both points that are
intersecting with the sphere
because usually, you will have
two of them, so the distance to
the closest one, and the
distance to the furthest
away one. We are going to define
the geometries. Our light source
will also be spheres but just
with a different material that
actually emit light and for that
we can test afterwards. We are
going to have a buffer for our
canvas, and we're going to
traverse through each pixel.
And we're going to trace for
each pixel one ray which is what
we did before, right?  In the
trace function, we want to see
again, this is the primary ray
that we talked about before, and
we want to see which is the
closest objects. We're going to
test the ray against every
object. And as a result, we get
the nearest one back. If we
don't have one, we can return
the background colour because
there's nothing there. And there
will never be something there.
That's the really cool thing
about raytracing. You actually
test against the
whole scene. If there is an
object there, and it's a
transparent or a reflective
material, we are going to have
to shoot the second race for
each of those, and we do this
recursively until we are
satisfied, and usually, you
don't want to do this endless by
because it is going to take
forever. So we're going to
decide how often you want to do
this recursion, and, at the end
of that, you will test it
against the light and see if
these points are in shadow or
not. Then you're going
to use the algorithm to see how
you should calculate the light
together. I'm not going to
explain that right now, but it
is very interesting look at. If
it doesn't fall into this, that
means we are hitting a light
source, or a diffuse material
that is not going to reflect on
the different points so we can
break the recursion there. I did
not make another slide for this
because I think it is clear.
This is the result we are
getting. I think it is very
interesting to see, from this
rather simple algorithm, we
already get really cool effects.
Like, we can really see the
spheres which are close to each
other, reflecting each other. We
can see shall quotes, and we can
also -- we can see shadows, and
what is behind thedows, and we
can also -- we can see shadows,
and what is behind the camera..
this is not something that you
see in games, for example, or in
different render engines. And
why is that? We're going to get
to that later on. So, this was
really easy, I think. But now we
want to really go realistic
because we said before there is
not one ray per pixel; usually,
the sun shoots so many rays that
make up one pixel of your image.
There are so many things that
come together, we want to have
soft shadows. We want to use
multiple light sources. How are
we going to compute these
together? How are we going to
decide on what is more weighted,
which pixel should be what? And
we really want to have this
physical correctness which means
that we have to basically bounce
the ray for ever until it hits
the light source by itself.
Right now, we're just making a
short cut because we just test
if it will be hitting the right
or not, if there is something in
between
or not. This is going to use a
lot of computational power.
Raytracing is an old technique.
1984 was the first conference
that was taking this as a topic,
and since then, we are still not
there where we have real time
raytraced engines that are
working. It has a lot to do with
this that you cannot make short
cuts to make it look good. You
have to have a certain amount of
samples, unless you're going -
otherwise you're going to have a
really noisy
scenery.
So we have a lot of new light
sources in the room that are
also casting rays. I would like
to just very
briefly interviews
to you rastarization technique.
This is the most common real
time technique being used. It is
just as fundamental, this
technique. It has been around
almost the same time because
when raytracing was introduced,
the computational power
notifications good or strong
enough. It would have taken them
forever to render one frame of
an animated movie, for example.
So, what is interesting
about
rasteriziation, it is trying to
find out which object is in the
shadow, or what is the colour of
it.
Raytracing is going from the eye
to the camera into the scene,
rasteriziation is going from the
objects from the scenery on to
the screen, due to perspective
projection. So we take all the
numbers and all our points, and
all our vertices and everything
and we project it on to the
screen. It is currently using
triangles, which is also a
rendering primitive. The cool
thing about triangles is that
you can't sub divide it any
more. You can't make more areas
out of it, and the area is
always planar, so we never have
a perspective warp or something,
which makes it really cool to
them project and test.
What we do with the triangles
mapped on to the screen base,
we're
rasterizing each pixel and map
its C value and measure how far
away it is from the camera, and
if we we have transparency, then
we have to consider the C buffer
because that's how we're going
to put it together, which also
tells us that the C buffer, so a
transparent object is basically
just a look-through with a
different alpha value which does
not have this refraction rates
that are warped around in
this scene. Here in this image,
you can see two basic
implementations:  one basic
images of rasterization, and the
implementation of raytracing.
You can already see the
difference, I think. While
rasterization has come a really
long way, if you have played any
3D games recently, or if you're
working with VR, you're going to
know it is not going to look
like thedifference, I think.
While rasterization has come a
really long way, if you have
played any image up there, so
there is a lot of simulations of
real physics happening in
rasterization but generally, the
implementation is also a lot of
work to do to simulate these
physics. But they are doing a
pretty good job. The only
probably is still transparency,
I think. So, just a quick
overview of the two:  raytracing
is mostly physically correct if
you put a rot of efforts in it.
It has nice side details that
you don't have to think about,
you get the soft shadows, the
interreflections, you get the
caustics, but it is
computationally heavy, so we're
going to use a lot of
computation time to render
frames, and, if we ever want to
do this real time, we're going
either have of to break it down,
or we have to make
cuts.
Rasterization is super fast. It
is really only one
transformation from your
co-ordinates to your screen-base
co-ordinates. Your GPU and your
computer is designed to do
rasterization, not raytracing.
Pixar and most of the rendering
people I know, they're still
rendering raytracing with CPUs
because it doesn't matter to
them if they're three times
faster or not. What matters is
that they have to change their
tools, and they have to change
their engines to be supportive
of GPUs. For just a little
benefit. So the physics that are
not really correct, you have
like approximation of what you
can do. And you
have quality loss due to that.
This is kind of the point where
I hope you are all, "Oh, God,
how should I even get started?
It seems very complicated." I
would like to introduce you a
frame tool kit, and A Frame of
is a web tool kit where you can
Alf get started with making your
own 3D scenes.
If you're a fan of HTML, you're
going to be really happy!
Because this is what it going to
look like. You can define the
HTML tags. You define the sky,
you can put sources in if you
want to use a sky texture. If
you prefer to use a sky colour,
you can put the colour. Then you
have this geometry primitives,
you have usually boxes, spheres,
cubes, whatever. Planes are also
very common, and you can also
define the lights. And that's
where we come back to the
beginning, because, with this
component, you're going to make
or break your scene. If your
lighting is
good, you can really achieve a
lot by just having three or
four, or five different objects
in the game. And the best part
of A Frame is that it comes with
web VR integration, so you don't
have to do anything. You can
lean back, you can import your
live controls, or every major
headset is supported. Also
mostly every major headset
controller is. So this is what
that example would
look like. But that did not look
very good. I mean, the
background does, but the
foreground ...!  So, it's still
the big question in the room is
how do I get my 3D models? That
is where also we come in. For
example, this is going to be in
the head of your HTML. You learn
the external components called A
Frame components and I think the
open-source community is really
doing an amazing job here
because you have all these
really cool components like A
Frame, orbit controls, people
building environment presets for
you so you can import them and
say I would like to use this
pre-set. Afterwards, you can
always use animation of each
attribute to change your scene
the way you want, and if you
don't like HTML, you can do that
with JavaScript. So you can just
edit your HTML attributes
programmatically to make them
animate. And this is how you're
going to use the A Frame
components that are made by
external parties, for example,
you can load the 3D IO furniture
of your choice, you can position
it because position attributes
are generallily used for each
object, and you can have your
camera, rotating around that
object, and you had this really
nice background that you love so
much. And you just want to lay
in that bed with that VR
headset. This is I think really
dev tool, and you should
definitely try it out because
there are so many, many things
that people are doing with this.
I would like to share with you a
few tips and tricks. This would
be a talk on its own, but this
is what I've been asked most of
the time. Again, how do I
get my content? Should I start
to learn Blender? That's a
pretty frustrating tool to
learn. I've worked a lot with
Blender, but it is pretty
powerful. However, you don't
have to do that because some
people, like my co-worker,
Thomas, is writing an inspector
plug-in for A Team, which has a
3D inspector to try out your
values that you can then import
into your HTML file.
You can use this inspector
plug-in to get models from
example Google Blogs. Try it
out, scale the models and have
fun with
it. Lighting is going to make or
break your scene. I think it
really makes a big difference.
If you're interested in this, I
have high motivations to write
blog posts about this topic. And
then for the end is content
optimisation. We are people that
work mostly with the web, and
with different devices.
So if you start working with 3D
for a project, think about what
is your target group. If you
want to use 3D on different
devices at the same time, keep
in mind you might want to design
it differently for whatever you
want to do. If you want to do a
fast-paced game, then you have
maybe to not be so detailed; but
if you want to do product, like
you want to do a scene of your
product which you try to sell,
you might want to be more
detailed on that. So, you should
be thinking about loading your
assets progressively. That means
you could have your textures in
different sizes or different
formats depending on what your
device is capable of doing. And
you should design for level of
detail. If there's an object
near scene that you are only
going to see two pixels, don't
make it have a million polygons,
please!  And these are all the
lessons that we have for free
from game development. Also, one
other lesson that we are
actually doing, or that I was
working on is we do use
raytracing for calculating light
simulation, for static scenery,
so the parts of our scenes that
are static, we use a raytracing
engine to calculate in the cloud
what is our realistic light, and
then we put it back into the
rasterization with the real time
stuff. This is a really cool
workaround. So two takeaways and
then I'm done. Models,
materials, and light do matter,
and this one is mostly for
myself:  I love raytracing, it's
really cool, but are we ever
going to have it real
time? And we are having cool
demos on this, but it is still a
question in a is unanswered.
Thank you very much for
listening. If there are any
questions, please ask my any
time. And this is to
get you started. Amazing
resources for any computer
graphics pioneers that would
like to get started, and really
to try the engine out for
themselves. A Frame is the tool
that I've been showing you if
you want to play around, and 3D
IO is what we've been working
with to provide the models.
Thanks.  [Applause].
>> Thank you, Madlaina. It's
break time. We have 38 minutes
from now. Everyone has to leave
here because we're taking down
that wall. And switching back to
one main hall. So, come back at
2.50 PM, please.
Ask questions on Slido.com if
you have not
already done so.
>> Shall be? Hello!
you Did Hello!  this
>> miss
duo?soundproof. nothing. so
heard Ahh!  No, we was right?
That on, going wall I couldn't
hear. I there was  like a
concert was quiet.heard It
askyour panel  can post  can
yet, you speaker
and youyou haven't heard
questions for the later,
question on sslido.com with the
and event
will be voted on code
[Applause].  asked.
>> In [Inaudible]. JSCONF.
Solet's talk [inaudible]. Your
question
>> And we are Martin. Martin is
a mapper, reducer. I just want
to say this, creator of JSFuck,
and co-founder of Union Labs,
and he used to argue  JSCons.
Martin!  [Applause].
MARTIN: Is it working? Yes, it's
working. Okay, perfect. Thanks
for the intro. We're going to
start quickly with our - this is
about Daedalus. You saw it in
the description, it's a bit
scriptic, but you will see a
pattern here during the talk,
because we're going to focus on
some parts of the Greek
mythology, and we have to have
the Maze as the labyrinth for
the topic. Let's
get started, and let's reveal
the topic. The topic today will
be creative coding in different
ways. I talked to many people
already, and they have different
ideas. I try to cover many
aspects of creative coding now
during this talk. The first one
I'm going to show is quite odd,
it's - quite old. It's five
years old. It is things I show
at JSConf in Berlin five years
ago. It is some script that is
1024 characters long, an HTML
page, and, once you run this in
a browser, you will see a
spinning globe inside of that
page. So, that's something that
we call a quine, a computer
programme that outputs its that
is modifying itself. You can see
this going on. Yes. Another
thing is this competition just
ended for 2018, the tenth time
the JS competition took place
which is a competition where
people can do something in 1K of
JavaScript with no external
resources. I just want to show
one example because I think it
is a good fit here, by Johnny
Jikanga, new on the scene, and
he created an animation showing
the northern lights. I picked
this because we are all waiting
for this. At least you saw it
virtually here.
Virtual reality. But I'm really
hoping to see it the next days.
It's really cool. You can see
some strange patterns going on.
I'm not going to go into the
detail because we don't have
much time. They closed the
competition, and you're able to
see the demo and see what is
going on in the background. Yes.
The second topic I want to talk
about is code golf. Code golf is
a mix of art, sport, and
programming. Because, you know,
from the term "golf", you try to
hit the ball into a hole with
the at least amount of strokes.
What you have here is you have a
problem that you try to solve in
the least amount of characters.
So you're trying to shorten it
as much as possible. A good
example here
is this makes Pacman, an old
game, and like the theme we came
up with was we would like to
create this Pacman game but with
the least amount of characters
that we have, and one thing that
you usually start with is reduce
the graphics, so, instead of
this nice little Pacman icon, we
have an X and a dot. It's like
you're able to distinguish - you
can see the -
the dots are the things that
you're going to collect. The 0
is the ghost and the X is the
Pacman.  You can move around,
collect all the dots. It is as
minimalistic, and the source
code is only 348bytes long.
collect all the dots. It is as
This was maybe two or three
years ago. It's not using some
year 6 things, so it could be
even shorter. Another thing is
instead of doing something small
with the result, we pick only a
subset of characters and do
something big, and it's another
project I'm famous for,
JSFuck,.js Beep here on the
stage!  What you can do is you
can have a web page where you
can enter your JavaScript, and
it will output code that you can
check and execute wherever you
like. It
only takes brackets, braces,
plus and ampersand as the
output. And this will be the -
so quite long, but quite
interesting to read. I have to
show this because it's like a
fundamental principle that we
are going to see in the next
example how this works behind
the scene. So what we are doing
here is, if we have not an MD
array, it will be converted into
naughts. If we don't have an MD
array, we have two, and if we
have the same, we get the string
falls and the - the stringfalls
and the string - string false
true - we can pick several
cashing degrees out of this
word. Zero would be a plus in
the empty area, and we can pick
out the character T. We've got
the character R, the character U
and the character E. If we then
take different words with
different characters and combine
them, then we can join them
again, and we can then create
new words out of this - for
example, "alert". That's
something I call playing
scrabble with the JavaScript, so
you have basic types, like
undefined true, objects, also he
undefined, as I mentioned, and
you can combine these characters
to new
words. One word that is super
important here is the
constructor. So we can get the
constructor as a string. And, if
you then take this constructor
and place it next to an empty
array and call constructor
constructor and then parsing
something, it is interesting
because first place will be
empty area constructor which is
basically the function, and, if
you have a function, and then
take the constructor, then we
have the function constructor
which lets us pass the code like
which is basically eval. So you
can combine this, and like
execute code without writing it.
Another example that recently
came up is similar to JSFuck,
uses the same mechanics, it is
symmetric - symmetric to
JavaScript.  The a simple
example. But, every column that
you see is symmetric. If you do
just reroutes here, and the see
the first row is the words, the
second row is the character
index, and the third row is to
add these characters. Yes, so
you get this alert again. That's
it for the first part. Was there
something? No. Oh.  Yes, here it
is. As you might have read in
the description of my talk, I
used the Daedalus writing and
the Latin alphabet and the Greek
version. The next part of my
talk was on different writing
systems that we have. For
example, Greek, we have
Cyrillic, Arabic, Korean, we
have Hebrew, and then Japanese,
and the last one. Who knows the
last one? It is A - I created a
website that is able to convert
your input last one? It is into
Arabish JavaScript, and you can
type not only different symbols,
you could write this as
Icelandic characters, or runes
with your axe, you can hammer
them in, so you get an output
like this which looks - but it
is auto --
Aurebesh. You can choose
different symbols, alpha bets,
then did will all do what you
want. For example, quite
interesting to do this, because
it uses this writing system, the
first ones, once you have this
on the iPhone or a Mac it will
crash. While preparing my
presentation, I had this
somewhere in the file system,
and I took some time to get it
back because I had to install
some software to not display
it.
This is JavaScript for some
machines. I like this personally
because it used German words,
like ja nein,
scnit - this is Aurebesh, you
might see this in a Star Wars
movie. You can play around with
that and make it more graphical,
like only using underscores,
only using the upper half of the
vertical repeat marker, the
representation to write
variables, and to sign them with
other variables. How does it
work? This is the simple example
where I used the Latin alphabet,
and you see, they are quite
distributed over code, and, in
the end, it's the same principle
as I showed you with the JSFuck
code, so we have strings and
single characters out of this,
and then you combine them to get
the constructor, key word, and
then you also have a way to get
an alert in there and execute
that. This is an odd one where
we use Hebrew. Once you have
Hebrew words in the code, it's
funny because browser might
switch depending on your browser
the writing direction. This code
is not read from right to left
but from right to left, which is
super interesting in
a way. Next step. We've seen
these variables and this, some
interesting ways
of hiding code. I think it is
the hangul until if a bet which
is used in the Korean alphabet.
They have a filler character.
This filler character doesn't
take up any space, and it's
invisible. But you can still use
this as a variable name in
JavaScript. So what you have in
the end is code that looks like
this, or actually, it is this.
And it's an odd version, I
shortened it a bit, so this is
alert one, and I call it the
invisible alert. It has some
character but you can't read
what's going on here.  Is yes.
You can do creative things with
that. When you see triple plus
signs, there's something where
it simply adds characters
together before you can have
something which looks like a fat
arrow, with the assignment of an
arrow function, or you can put
backslash backslash into your
code. It looks like a regular
comment but it is a regular
expression. So what I did is I
combined these two aspects and
have something that looks like a
comma in
the beginning, and something, a
bit of ping, empty string in the
centre of the code, you will see
what is going on, and, if I
reformat this, I put this
into a script, this is the
source code of an HTML page, and
if I execute, it will show you
the void in an animated way.
The missing link is here how to
buy invisible code. This is
quite easy to do, so you can use
fillers or something from the
first ASC IoT page that still
takes up space, but on a second
ASC IoT page, there
are -- ASC IoT page
you can wrap them in a string
and you can have a small snippet
that will - so this is the code
we're going to use.
We are going to replace every
third and sixth characters and
join them
together with the backslash.
To give an example. These are
some control characters. We get
this percentage sign in front.
Numbers. We strip them away, and
then we combine every third and
sixth characters, and escape
them, and once we have that, we
have the other one.
[Applause].
Thank you, thank you. It's just
the beginning!  [Laughter].
Let's go back to the Greek
mythology. I showed this
labyrinth - I'm not sure you
know the different between a
maze and a labyrinth? The has
many ways and the - the Maze has
many ways and the labyrinth. The
half man and half bull is eating
boys and girls that enter into
the labyrinth. What I like here
is that it has two aspects, it
is man and also the bull, and
there is something similar in
programming which is called
polyglots, which is a computer
programme that is written in
different languages at the same
time, and depending on the
compiler, it will execute
something different.
I thought can we build jpeg,
HTML and CSS at the same time? I
created this page called
Inception, and this is when you
look at it, you have this image
in
there. We need to go deeper, and
you can see some characters.
What it does is basically, it's
like one page with four
different types in it.
It's hard to explain. I'm trying
my best now. So, what happens is
that the browser opens the
file, and we will run it as an
HTML page. This HTML page has
the script with the source to a
hash. That will force it to load
it to the JavaScript. This
JavaScript will write a link tag
also pointing to hash and
interpret it as CSS, and this
CSS file then has a background
URL which is empty which also
takes the same page again, and
renders this in the browser.
Okay. Maybe a bit more in the
detail. We have the HTML which
is - whenever we open the
document for the first type, the
content type is an indicator
what to do with that, so it's an
HTML file. We simply have
something going on, but the most
important thing is we have to
attack our own tag called
inception. And another thing
where we have a script tag with
the chart set to lesson one
which points to the same
picture. This is now loading the
JavaScript, and you see the
first variable here is a bit
strange. It's a bit like - it is
an object with the property
inception that is with the value
of
TT, and yes, the next line is
something strange because it
will multiply inception with an
object that has a property that
calls the function URL. So, you
might see the problem here
because JavaScript will fail if
it is not valid, and, in this
case, it would not be valid
because it doesn't know the URL
function, and it doesn't have
inception as a variable. What we
do later is we see inception and
function URL, and this will
hoist the thing to the top, so
it's valid. And then, we have
some comments that will hide
code that we don't need but make
sure that it is valid. The most
important thing here is that
we're going to write a link tag
pointing to the same page to
load the style sheet. So this is
the style sheet now. The same
page again. The first one is a
strange selector. So it tries to
find a tag with this strange
name, and then it has this other
equals sign.
It not defined but it's valid
syntax. It will want to know
what is going on here.
The third line here, this is
something that is not valid in
CSS and what is happening in CSS
is that once the browser or once
the browser has found something
that it is not valid, it will
break and not execute or follow
on, so it will only focus on the
second line here which is that
every tag inside of our
inception tag will have the
background URL with the same
page. Yes. And this now loads
the same page again. The jpeg.
The most important thing here at
the beginning, and then the
image data, and everything that
you see in the green, the
yellow part is metadata that
will simply be ignored in the
display. If we look at the hex
editor, it looks like this, but
you can zoom in to see what is
going on, FFE8 FFE1 is the eider
that says that is a jpeg. The
follow two bytes, they define
the helpful header side, so they
- the hex header size saying we
take up the bites to do the --
take up the bytes to do the
thing we want to do. If we look
at the hex presentation and, for
example, convert it to ACSII, we
can see that this is looking
similar.SCII, we can see that
this is looking similar. This is
out of the defined range. As you
remember before, we forced the
look at 1
one ISO589/1 encoding, and this
will turn our first hex codes
into something that is a valid
JavaScript area, but yep. That's
it. So this is the page that you
will see in the end, and I call
this Inception. [Applause].
Daedalus. Maybe I have to
explain a bit more, so this is a
odd picture about Daedalus.
Daedalus, he was the inventor of
the first labyrinth on the
island Crete, and he was - I'm
not sure if you know the story,
son Icaru is who flew too close
to the son and fell into the
see. It is a tragic story. But
what I want to take here is
later, the one who got into the
labyrinth and tried to hill the
Taurus. If you studied computer
signs, you might have come
across the project. But what I
wanted to do is to draw a
labyrinth, or tool, a maze in
this case, because it has many
ways and JavaScript. This is the
lay-out I've chosen, and instead
of walls, I had code. This code
is also valid. You can copy it,
and it will output a bigger
maze. To take some
steps further, I first tried to
minimise it. This is now the
whole programme that you need to
generate this maze. It's only
133 bytes and it was originally
created by EDC65. I don't know
his real name, unfortunately,
but I was able to get it down so
we can play around with that.
During my studies, I came across
a
project called
Tasors where he is known as the
father of the information
theory, and he always created
crazy machines.
And one example, some people say
the first example of machine
learning that he created was the
so-called Theseus project and it
had two different phases - the
training phase and the testing
phase. It was
all working mechanically in
1952. He could set up a maze.
There was a mouse in there, and
the mouse tried to find
the Maze. So this is the
exploration strategy, so you
see, it's bumping against the
wall, it's moving back, and
tried to find this. There's the
second thing. Once it hit the
goal, wherever you place the
mouse, it will go straight to
the goal without bumping against
walls. And what is interesting
here is the algorithm behind
because it fits on a sheet of
paper, and, so sum this up, the
exploration strategy, it reads
the direction where it come in.
It will rotate by 90 degrees,
move the mouse, and go back if
there was a wall and do it
again. It will always try to
return by 90 degrees, and then
try to move again. Yes, it is
the exploration strategy, and
this has been proved that we
always find the goal. Once it
has the goal, it switches to
something called the goal
strategy, and it's the same
thing but without the rotation
part, and it won't hit any wall.
So it reaches the direction
where it enters, or last level
the cell, and it moves the
mouse, so it will go directly to
do both. And to put this in a
code, it's only 256 bytes. The
first part is to create the
Maze, the second part is to
solve this maze, and this part
is only to render the Maze, and
to see what the output looks
like, it will draw a maze with
hashes and the Os. They are the
way out. It will create a maze
and also solve
the Maze. An animation to show
you what is going on. This is
the representation used in the
background. This is the more
visible representation where you
can see the arrows around, and
always turn them by 90 degrees
until it finds
the goal. Five minutes left. So
this talk was all about creating
the different aspects about
creative coding, how people can
squeeze code, how they do
visual stuff, and one thing that
is important here and super
interesting in our language that
we use in JavaScript is the
community behind, because
everything that you see, you can
look to the source code to see
what is going on. In the 1980s,
there was this scene where they
were trying to hide their
source, not show how they did
it, and this switched in the
JavaScript community, because
everything was visible, and that
is also a nice slack channel if
you want to get involved into
this. Once you have there, you
have a form to sign up. It was
established by
Maxime Auxillere. There are
discussions coming on. People
are discussing how to improve
stuff, and it's super
interesting. I want to use the
last two minutes, two and a half
minutes, to show you more
demos.
Another website is popping up,
and what you can do here is you
can, similar to JS Bin, so you
type in some code, and the
update will be instant once you
type, and you have exactly 140
characters to do something. And
what they also do, they provide
you with some short cuts. For
Xenos, you have the capital S,
you have the access to the
canvas with a C. There's also
some savings. You have 140
characters left to do whatever
you like. So it's good play
around. It lists the examples,
if you can vote on this, and you
can see, for example, a game of
life. 140 characters. You can
see a 3D fish swimming in the
pool. That was something I was
working on, so we tried to find
the shortest way to render ocean
waves in only 66 bytes,
and we have wave casting that
fits on a business card!
[Applause].
We have this crazy tuna going
on.
The roller coaster, and really
crazy example stuff. It is We
have this crazy tuna going on.
like code pam, you can discover
them.
Once you've found something that
is interesting, for example,
this piece where it will draw
the ball, so, it is basically a
bit map
encoder, it draws the ball. You
can use this to create your own
forks out of this. I create
something different here, so I
had a
spinning globe made
using some formula, and another
one come up with the spinning
sphere, and we tried to reduce
this until we only had 77 bytes,
and I said let's combine this
one with the bitmap rendering
which took some time, but, in
the end, Matthew Henri came up
with the spinning world in 140
bytes. He managed to create a
bitmap that looks like the world
map on a spinning sphere. This
was not the end, so I tried to
do something different with
that, and the in the
end, Chun came up with the
coloured version of that. It has
some glitches. The one I started
was about 500bytes that you saw
in the beginning, and this is
only 140 bytes. You learn a lot
when you cross these examples
and read the comments about
that.
That's it. Check out Twitter,
and I also would say it's now
your turn to be creative. Some
people ask why is it helpful not
only to learn more about the
language, so you discover new
ways of doing things, it also
helps you to organise codes
because, in the first place, you
don't compress it, you have to
lay out the code really nice to
keep track of it, and one thing
that is also, you have to focus
on the problem, and you have to
break down the problem, and
really focus on the minimal
aspect in there, and this is
something that I always take out
of this, and I want to give this
away to you and say, okay, try
this out. So, thank you, thanks
for listening.
[Applause].
Other examples are my website. I
will tweet about the
presentation in a minute, and,
if you download this, examples
are clickable. It will be
redirected to the original URL.
No, it won't break your Mac!
I'm a good guy. This isn't about
bad security, it is about
creative fun.
>> That was amazing. Thank you
so much. I'm supposed to come up
with questions that I'm so
mind-blown, I can't think of
any. I've got one:  if you can
have dinner with any character
from Greek mythology, who would
you pick?
MARTIN: It's a good question.
Actually, I would have dinner
with Pathi. He is the nephew of
the Dedelus, but he had a
nephew, and he taught, he taught
him all the things that he knew,
and then he saw that Padix was
even better than him, so he was
the one who created the circle,
the compass, and the crazy other
things, so Daedelus tried to
kill him, and he turned into a
bird, but he was like really
good.
>> You must be fun at parties!
MARTIN: Yeah!
>> Thanks so much for a great
talk and lessons in mythology.
[Cheering and Applause].
>> What happened to your suit,
>> What happened to your
cry.
suit
We
later, That's
unfortunate, I'm
>> Don't can try to find your
Florida?
I guess.  sorry.
But ... . It's okay. In like the
maybe. 1980s,
webpack know that Well, 4 wasdid
youof, I outdon't want to
days, right? approximately 120
hoursingfaster but I  that is I
five the think,sounds  hell,
looked at better.  It's supposed
to be I as job and and
think know thatsurprise, also,
good generic  log, don't 203
spoil the  and had very I'm
change so I it asummarising so
bullet points, I'm going to do
to  it, going to leave it
it  How'stalk  everybody. last
I and like compiler web how
That
>> What'smany, this [Cheering].
really like, maintain going?
great. to tiny was I freaking
character wondered myself, from
the title
Yes, thank take tricks can So
Sean! this we this? you.
programme is, "Webpack talk 4:
project know  the State ofEdge
working a and may a the Edge,
teenager of the you Larkin,
working on the Microsoft
manager,team,  Art." manager at
Microsoft, the main  But atme
just I'm being one of time
DevTools.  core  as spent and
Seanopen-sourceMicrosoft and
webpack CLI,  and also represent
general for Angular with and
now, a involvement evangelist
sustainability, helping  with my
technical webpack, a I'mtired
you all at the  is Node rogue. I
got Js pegoneabout myself
foundation. So support re  was
That script? then Apple not
being able a little wrotefirst
of to andfinally, Like, who
internet  Ruby,woodworking and
people's problems. bit   like
Then also and my programming
language. IObjective-C,practices
I found JavaScript.passions
open-source  I Butsaid,  of
things. my  like me  most
sustainablefollowing. You is in
one of  latest find that I've
been anywhere,general like can
where,places.
of those the art. places, of the
state 4, any
Webpack the okay. with @the can
find me on Back to talk,  to
definition. Is Larkin.  wanted
pull little
State of stay the do art:  I
sure.  up a we would
You that how what you not  call
A I'mabout the it? tostand off
the stage list? talking
development, don't want
We did You know, we're recent
want of  or Itoday.guard, active
- release   at but  Andleast
Garde but 4 ago. latest hours
Avant Webpack latest. webpack
120 the incan release It's  it's
here. is out. Youmajor get it
we  talk totoday. I want about
what time,decided webpack ouris
called 4might the first anybody
to take You  and give
represents. major releases a
Legardo. codename. This music if
webpack
So, I'm a whatstill so be,
understand forelse  You in
college,manner without  did
music. ourwanted flowing this
Legto  means, in  itthem. is
Trivago. We got notes in a to
fromfor gaps sponsor, between
express  sponsors But we the
term  major largest to give
opportunity  one ofso our major
explanation. the  theirto name
release, and  this was
projects a
TheirHarmony, side,  PHP
Symphony, and theme. we
At Trivago  give oura name the
and hauled musical it what
melody, on embodied old
framework was really them
expressive then tomeaning  note,
gaps, each Legato, to play
without throughmeant to have
want more, I want explain
webpack Before 4 in slides, at
each of these just  go on and
their I your at one system. I
yourself, build see you to look
or right you thereof them. If up
company you to stand
want you to give them a round of
applause. now. I [Cheering and
Applause]. Because, without
piece theme, we would not be
here today. Webpack 4 may not
exist. So, I just wanted to take
a second and recognise
those people. So, you know, we
wanted to create this
higher-level story about webpack
4 meant for our universities,
meant for us, and so the first
thing with smaller buildings and
faster buildings. The second was
modernisation. Finally, probably
one of the most important, what
I mean, all of these are really
important, and not mutually
exclusive, which is developer
experience. And if I talk about
smaller and faster buildings,
and we try and break it down,
you can kind of categorise it
here. So like to have a smaller
build, you're going to need to
do more analysis on the
code.
You're going to have to process
more of the module graph, and
for faster buildings, you're
going to have to do less work
and reuse existing work that's
already been done. So these are
kind of conflicting, but for
faster buildings, we - builds,
we rearchitected what a chunk
is. It's the in-memory version
of the thing you secreted. We
added additional features like
JS. We're going to be using it
in parallel and caching it out
of the box. We also modernised a
lot of the pieces that we had in
just old ES5 objects syntax, and
we used to moving maps
and sets.
Significantly, one of the most
important is the migration of
our plug-in system. We wrote it
completely from the ground
up.
Now, we have what are called
hooks which are monomorphic
code, and we lazy-compiled them.
I want to take a moment to
explain what does this even
mean? Who here is familiar with
monomorphism or Polly
morp -
this may look available to prior
to rewriting it. If you see
here, this method is what
certain classes in webpack will
call and plugins are listening
to this event, and what is
parsing is an arbitrary event
stream. It is like an event
emitter if you've ever used it
before. The problem is that this
is Polly morphic. It can be any
amount of arguments. There's no
way for the JavaScript engines
to optimise this.
Why don't we get clever and have
single arguments for all of
them. You can have an infinite
amount of different event names
and  Why don't we get clever and
have single argument types that
you can parse in, so it's
unmaintainable and not really a
great contributor experience, so
it's, like, how could we solve
this where we are creating
monomorphism functionings - mono
morphic functions but they're
unique, and we don't have a
billion of them we don't have to
maintain? We use the technique
to lazily compile based on what
is listening to these events. I
know I'm going a little deep
here, but it might make more
sense in a moment. You can see
at the bottom, we are literally
just composing a bunch of
strings that our JavaScript
compiled to these hooks, and
then we evaluate it. So a really
great resource if you're
interested in this, and I will
try not to butcher the name,
Egerov wrote a great explain
article that you can go to and
take a look at it to understand
how this Acomb accomplishes
monomorphic code. You may - you
may not need Rust and - it turns
out, that looks pretty familiar.
The code that he show cased.
Look, he's doing the same thing.
So the point is that we can read
this monomorphic code but we're
doing it evaluatatively or
lazily compiling it. Please to
not do it on normal projects.
There are some parts of webpack
that execute 19 plumb times on
large code basis, so everything
is in the hot path for us. So
just as Benedict Moyer says,
don't, please don't do this.
Please don't do this. So, like,
what did this
represent to us?
On most webpack builds, we saw
it get 98 per cent faster. 98
per cent of the build time was
reduced just by people upgrading
to webpack four. 98. [Applause].
And you will be, "John, you're
lying - Sean, you're lying,
stop!" It turns out we had
people reporting reporting six
hours of webpack 3, nine hours
and stopped it at 6 on this run.
And so we were like, we have -
yes, and after the showcasing
this in the webpack 4 alpha, we
found 17 minutes - 17 minutes -
from mine hours. There's the
URL. You can go to it. I'm not
lying. And just to make sure, so
that people are, "You're still
lying," once we had gotten to
our release candidacy, I decided
to play a little game to see
could we get people to upgrade
to the beta so we can catch
early bugs, warning signs,
things like that? Two, it's like
this speed boost, is this for
real? Yes, I shot this out, and
like we were seeing 75 per cent.
In some cases, we were seeing 90
per cent, 80 per cent. So it's
the real
deal. Build speed, to sum it up,
we were able to accomplish that
first piece in what our goals
were. Then we still had smaller
builds. Now we had to do
something basically opposite to
what trying to get a faster
build will do for you. So the
first thing that we tried to
implement, and we were able to
do so, is JSON tree-shaking. If
you ever used JSON with webpack,
you will notice that, in version
3, it would bundle all the
pieces you import into it. We
found out that JSON is just a
stricter set of what JavaScript
is, and so we could treat it
like an atmospheric module, and
only the pieces that are now use
will actually get - will stay in
your code. In this case, you can
just see, we're pulling in and
importing one property, and that
is all that compiles when we
minify
the code. We also have a future.
I will explain the problem
first. So, according to module
specification, or the Harmony
module spec, when you have
multiple exports inside of a
file, every single one of them
has to be evaluated and executed
to ensure that they are not
creating side effects against
each other. So what does that
mean? Well, if low dash is
exporting from a file
essentially 1,000 exports, each
one of them has to be included
into your
bundle. You can see that here in
this tiny
example.
We created this trick. We had to
tell the compiler some way there
are no side effects here, you
can go ahead and ignore those
properties. So that is what we
did. We created the side effects
property which now we're asking
library authors to include in
their package JSONs because what
webpack will do in production
mode is it will look for the
presence of this report, and it
will simply prune it out. And,
in fact, it actually makes
buildings faster when we're in
the beta stage that we found our
production builds were faster
than the development mode build
because of this feature, because
what you're doing is ignoring
tracing those parts of the - so,
in this case, we thought
something like in webpack 3,
200kb of minimised code turned
actually to 1kb.
So, really all you need to do,
it's so easy, all you have to do
is just tree-shake, minimise,
and then package authors had the
side side effect. No!  That's
ridiculous. You should not have
to do any of that. That kind of
gets into what developer
experience is about. All you
should have to do is freaking
run webpack. So out of the box
now in webpack 4, we default to
a production mode. All of those
things you saw in that bullet
point, they just happened. So
developer experience to us meant
we need to lower the barrier to
entry to people who are trying
these tools for the first time.
Not everybody understands the
rigorous and obnoxious history
of JavaScript modules where they
started and where they are now.
We also need to have better
defaults, and thanks to
libraries like Parcel, we can
coin something like zero config
JS. For us, zero config doesn't
mean doing whatever you want and
shoving it into one package and
hope in the future you don't use
breaks and cause the major
breaking change, it means being
able to actually extend a base
scenario to your users, so you
can bring your own zero config
JS. This is the line that we
wanted to cross. So, you know,
by default, you don't need a
webpack configure to use webpack
4. Every property has been
defaulted. And what the future -
[Applause].  What I'm trying to
say shall not everyone will end
up ripping up their webpack
because the power of webpack is
deeply rooted in how extensible
we are.
Instead, why don't we extend
this idea? We created this
feature called mode. It's a
property on the config or a flag
that you can pass on the CLI,
and we default to production,
like I said. What it represents
for development is you want to
have tooling for the browser.
You're going to want to have
really fast incremental
compilation, and you're going to
have better error messages that
don't take up an entire console.
And then for production, we are
optimising for size. We are
optimising for the right kind of
source code, and we are opt
missing for file paths that are
understandable but don't leek,
you know, information - don't
leak the information to people
using your website. It also
means getting rid of things that
really used to cause us
problems. Webpack 4, it's gone.
We've replaced it with an API
that does much of this out of
the box by default. But on top
of that, we have properties that
give you more control than
common chunks did. Then finally,
build speed was something we
took so seriously, that we
wanted to be able to profile and
analyse really deeply any
long-running build. And so, we
worked with Sam Siconi from
Google who helped us implement a
special profiler that allows you
to see every plugin and how long
it takes, right inside of the
DevTools timeline viewer online.
[Applause]
You. It allows us to say pop in
a plug-in and send us the event
in the JSON file. It is really
useful for those who You. It
allows us to are creating
plugins themselves, and trying
to
analyse interactions. That kind
of leaves us to the
modernisation and the
architecture. Is to so, one of
the most important things that
held us back in webpack 3 is
that we treat everything as a
JavaScript
module. But we also were
championed with being able to
implement web assembly as a
first-class citizen, giving us
the opportunity to remove all of
these everything is.js hacks, or
- everything is JS hacks or
allowed us to WASM and a method
actual type and enable JSON, and
we are now working on HTML and
CSS module types. We had to
remove from our module factories
what we call them all the code
generation systems that were
specific to JavaScript, and we
isolated it. And so now, with
web assembly as a first-class
module type, you have code like
this. This is a newer library
called Walt. It is a
subset of TypeScript. It allows
you to write a JavaScript-like
syntax, as you see at
the top, is it and all you have
to do is import it like a
JavaScript module into your
code. You have used web assembly
without doing anything else at
your fingertips.
[Applause].  This is probably
one of the most exciting things
to me is that you want to use A
Frame or you want to use these
things. Now, what these library
authors can do is instantly
compile a web assembly module,
and, if it's available in the
package, webpack will consume
that instead of the JavaScript.
So you get the 10x speed-up
instantly at your fingertips. So
the other pieces were dropping
Node 4, so that is no longer
supported for webpack and Node 6
is our minimum version. But this
allowed us to convert the rest
of the code base to using ES6
features. It allowed our code to
be more readable. Easier to
change. Using syntax that people
understand and contributors
actually want to leverage. And
now, you know, by using this new
code, V8 has a great test bench
for optimising paths that aren't
That was great for our team who
own the score
own the score plug-ins and
loaders, but it was a lot harder
for third party
plugins.
>> We will focus more on
providing plugins and updating,
versus having a
moreJavaScript no see this year
of  being talk of this fatigue.
time window.
Instead,  The technology. part
embracing the every our most we
what framework it's beautiful
oflanguage is that without
weeks. In see a new yet you two
exist otherto doesn't no other
is  language do that  get  use
count!  There Java VM syntax
doesn't youthis. a that for
language. It growthpeople
becauseRenaissance. And embrace
JavaScript even a  is a we We it
Microsoft. so, at We callmind
set ask you to
guys so  another you do the same
ﾣ . Help not just be build tool.
Thank webpackmuch. Yeah,
and try
>> Okay, ahead. Yes.
>> I know that webpack 4,
dealing wise to some on tried
>> your the wordsget weevenof
with those?  So, to  I think
best is then wayfor things and
started channel  thecreate it
like a doing, unified talking
about before documentation.that
we've been So, one you into the
can provide resources just gets
like, "John, like beon and blast
me  Twitter  Ionewhat do but you
I do?"  will send you  of these
resources tocan go
medium.com/webpackchanges,  and
migrate making to posts are
webpack cause howwould the
reaching andas   either might
them,  other things GitHub or
that say best last available
problems. Beyond that on be to
we would as the just an issue we
way,way. can forward be out us
four that is  Weresources try to
and possible onnot Twitter,   a
and you
>> or other one, things.
Awesome, thank you.webpack
serious
>> I I think have a one! starred
most serious the on is one of
projects open-source
being GitHub. It a really big
get What wouldcommunity effort.
you to  any advisetrying like
someone who wanted to is
involved,
>>entry-level on wayand diverse
to contribute?   focused the
Yes, one ofthings Absolutely.
doesn't inclusive  we really
thatalthough to create an  so
communityintimidating
intimidating,  codefirst feel be
check out our  can  isthe
sometimes, the place we say the
has Mediumcontributingcodes our
read me whichpublication, we  On
guidelines and ofcalled conduct.
what  overview of give have a It
thing like whole the guide. you
package will you the and, if
thiscertainto expect, tryacross
two  have  organisations things,
Because we out. forpackages. And
point whole  people 100 the
different open like about that
so, is is us a know, regardless
of  you source come skills who
have something, those they
applyingpassion for andbetter,
and wherefind different  and, we
webpack to a way like that makes
and  SPG an expert, so, or no
try or or writing,
opportunities, matter if
designer, you're aif you are a
anything!
>> so impact. well And find
imply that way veryready can
try to we're a think was that
you I
Thank Sean. That said.  next
you, for our
speaker.
on].
>> Sarah's very accomplished,
and award-winning speaker,
writer, author, senior cloud
developer, advocate at
Microsoft, and I mean, I don't
think I need to list any more
accomplishments, because it is
a long list.. let's hear it from
Sarah. [Applause].  I
>> I want to thank the MCs and
the organisers for having such a
long list.. let's hear it from a
great conference, so give them a
round of applause!  [Applause].
I'm going to ask something of
you. Everyone in this room, I
would appreciate it if you would
take your phones out and hold
them in your hands. You can do
turned
it!  Pass your phone to the
person
on your right. Look at that
phone, feel it, recognise
it, but you almost can't do
that, right? Because you're on
your right. Look at that phone,
feel it, so distracted thinking
about your phone in someone
else's hands.
Oh, it's awful!  It's just
awful!  And the thing that I
want to bring up here is that
the reason that we feel this way
is that our phones are now an
extension of ourselves. These
phones become who we are, and
our connection to that data.
Pete Spark makes this point when
he talks about designing for
human computer interaction,
which we will talk a little bit
about today when he talks about
our relationship with
technology, but we're going to
talk about it with a different
stint. We're not going to talk
about the device itself but how
we relate to the peck logical
advances. You can pass the
phones back now!  There are a
lot of different takes about
living our lives increasingly
online, and, if you're in this
room, chances are, as we adopt
things digitally, you got
excited. We were thinking about
all the things that we could
build or make, and carriosity
for how we can represent
ourselves online.
[Music]. We have geocities which
is like a bastion of internet
explosion. I can't make
something this good.
Nobody can. That's just it. We
reached the pinnacle right at
the beginning. Then MySpace.
Everyone was friends with Tom,
and in putting this talk
together, I revisited mine which
was a time capsule to terrible
bangs, weird old art pictures,
and weird pictures of me in a
bathroom. I don't know. It was a
phase. Some people might not
have started developing with
dragon ball Z but they started
because they wanted to be elite
hackers so good at programming
that their fingers were
literally on fire. Whatever our
interests were, the internet
allowed us to explore and share
our lives and express ourselves
in creative, bizarre,
interesting, and unique ways
that only a collectivity of
humans could imagine. But the
only constant is change. Soon,
we had so many ways of being
represented online, and so many
people were online, that we
needed to automate these tasks.
We need something that could
analyse, build, manage, and sort
for us. And, as things become
more complicated, what we
realise is all of our lives
become summations of these
digital models. We become pieces
of someone else's algorithms
which means we could be
summarised in a single way. So,
people are starting to use
search engines rather than
libraries or teachers to make
sense of the world we're
inhabiting. These inaccuracy
started to be reflected in what
we learn and believe in. They
become our societies and our
education. Tech can be super
magical in this way, right? It's
such a cool thing that we can
all be here together for the
same reason in Iceland. But just
like any other software we
write, the more magic it
contains, the more it can
fail.
I'm Sarah Drasner, and I work or
Microsoft. Today's talk is
called Live and Machine Learn.
[Applause].
In this talk, we will explore
the paradigm shift that
machine-learning brings and do
that through how machine
learning works. We don't have a
tonne of time to go into it, but
we're going to talk about
challenges to democracy through
machine-learning. We are also
going to talk about
machine-learning for good.
Machine-learning does a lot of
cool things, and we're going to
talk about those too. We're
going to talk about some of the
practical tech that we all know,
so not necessarily
machine-learning but how we can
make a difference with some of
the things that we know today.
Let's talk on a high level about
what machine-learning is and
kick it off by the quote from
the fellow who coined the term:
machine learning gives computers
the ability to learn without
being explicitly proceeding. We
are programmers, we're familiar
with if-then statement. What if
the conditions for these
statements become complex? I
mean really complex? If you're
building a programme to
understand that this is a pug,
and this is a kitten, you don't
necessarily want to programme an
if statement for every single
pixel here, or the possibility
for every pixel for every single
pug photo. That's not how our
brains work, right? How do you
programme it? You want to teach
it a certain puliness. You want
your model to learn the essence
of the pug. So, in truth, there
are a few ways of doing this.
Sometimes, like the example
above, we can tag a set of data
and your model will use this
supervised data set to
distinguish between these
classes and this will help it
learn better. This is called
supervised machine learning. But
there are other times where we
don't really know the answer, so
if I asked a computer what those
pugs would look like if bred
together with Stegosauruses,
that's not really a thing!  So,
there's nothing we can check
against. That's when we will use
an unsupervised process. But
let's dive into supervised
process because it's the east to
explain in the time we have, and
it's also pretty common. Within
supervised machine learning,
there are thousands of
algorithms that you could use,
and among those convolutional
neuronetworks are probably the
most popular, but genetic is the
easiest to understand, so we're
going to use that to kind of
discuss things on a
high level today. Let's explore
a simple toy model. In order to
make a pug kitten-sorter, we
build an algorithm that builds
algorithms. It will build many
of these and they will do their
best to sort these, and do their
best sorting. At first, they
will be bad at it. They will be
terrible. But, we have another
function that will check this,
and they will check it against
that tagged data, and, for every
kitten and pug scenario, so the
ones that get it wrong, they are
thrown away, and the ones that
get it right, circle back to the
builder, and then the builder
starts using those to create new
builders. Now, this might seem
hackie and imperfect, and that's
because it is. If we did this
once, twice, or three times, it
would fail, but we do it
thousands of times. We don't do
it for a small amount of
conditions, either. We build up
all of the gradients that make
up an eye, and then we match it
up against all of the other ice
that we know of, and then we
match that against the
likelihood of snouts. Our own
classification system,
genus et cetera is composed of
this set of rules. The part I
want you to remember is this
moving forward.
The point where we check, you
can see how that is a very
important part of this. We have
to check if we want to get the
data right. We must do so, and
keep on checking. Another really
important part here is if I only
gave these pug pictures that it
was fed on, that would be
correct, right? These are all
pugs, but what might happen is
that it might fail when it's
trying to find our one true pug.
So the type of data that we
train on is really vital to
whether or not we have an
accurate model. Okay. So let's
explore some ways that
machine-learning has failed but
I'm going to call this section
the road to hell is paved with
good intentions. None of what
I'm showing this here today is
made with the idea of corrupting
society. Quite the opposite. All
of these are really
well-intentioned examples. But
their failure is good for us to
explore so that we don't fail in
the future. So let's say you
need to patrol a city but you
don't have enough patrol units
completely to cover this city.
So it might make sense to figure
out where all the crime is
happening. And just have some
patrol units that focus on the
areas of most activity. But the
problem is, not all crime is
equal. To get enough data, you
have to include nuisance crimes
in which no-one is hurt like
homelessness or pan-handling
with the violent crimes like
rape and murder but they don't
tend to be clustered in this
way. It takes a lot more data to
build an area which is why the
nuisance data is included.
Another issue that those
nuisance data areas tend to be
the poor areas. What ends up
happening is you get more patrol
areas in the poor areas, and
then we have more data on those
patrol areas, and we get into
this weird feedback loop where
we're just patrolling those and
then the rapes and murders that
happen in the affluent areas
start not to be reported. This
is what the software does in the
United States, and it's an
example of sample bias, in
machine learning. We found once
you're a criminal, you're likely
to become a criminal again. A
lot of people keep re-offending.
They found the reason people do
this is that they find it hard
to fit back into society once
they're in jail. Another thing
is that employment becomes more
difficult because you have to
disclose that you were once in
jail on your employment forms,
and then people are less likely
to employ you. But here's an
important part. Employment tends
to be the number-one indicator
of whether you're going to end
up back in prison. Even the
analysis of who ends up in the
system uses machine-learning,
so, when most defendants are
booked in jail, they respond to
a questionnaire fed into a
system that defines the risk
level for used in the length of
their sentencing. Whether you're
in for a short amount of time or
a long amount of time. An
evaluation of more than 10,000
of these people found that the
risk scores showed a startling
difference. Black defendants had
scores pretty evenly matched
across the board - one meaning
no, and then you have a very
long sentence, whereas the white
risk assessments look quite
different:  many are assessed at
1, steadily decreasing to very
few at 10. You might say what if
that is just valid data? Except
upon analysis, it is not really.
The studies showed that blacks
were twice as likely to be
labelled higher risk and not
re-offend, while their white
counterparts labelled not as
risky. If we look at this in
human terms, we see James
Ravelil - Ravelli had a
aggravated assault, drug
tasking, and he subsequently did
re-offend. Robert canon had one
petty theft. There are more too.
Lu go. O, low risk at one.
Mallory Williams, medium risk at
6. Lugo had three DUYs, Williams
had two misdemeanours and never
offended again. This is just a
couple of them. There's a lot.
These kind of algorithms don't
just affect black people,
either. A construction worker
who sold a piece of equipment
and sold it for parts low on
cash, since then, he's been
going to church and volunteering
but says his risk score doesn't
indicate any of the ways he is
bettering himself as a person
and therefore not a good
indicator of whether or not he's
going to offend again. What
makes Compus fail as a
machine-learning algorithm? One
is that it has no transparency.
You make the algorithm, and then
they are sending it out.
Basically be the people who are
using it don't know how it
works. Another thing is, because
of this, because of that
relationship, it doesn't adapt
over time. Remember, we talked
about how important that step of
adapting is. And related to
these things, people use it
without any question. Another
question that might be asked at
this time is whether this is a
good place for machine-learning
algorithms. Machine-learning
algorithms are super powerful
and really wonderful but
sometimes, this should be in the
hands of a judge. Here's the
main thing about
machine-learning algorithms:  we
try to be predictive of the
future but machine-learning
algorithms can really only
evaluate the past. So, Brennan,
one of the co-creators of this
technology didn't build the
technology with the idea of the
use for sentencing. That's the
strange thing about some of this
tech. Once you put it in the
world, adoption can be beyond
us. Anyone who maintains an
open-source project will say
that sometimes you put something
out in the world, and the way
people use it is totally
different than the way you
intended or the way you had
foreseen. This is why it is
critical for these types of
technologies to be transparent
in order not to be abused. They
can't be magical. People will
say algorithms can't be biased.
But algorithms are written by
people. So this doesn't always
happen to criminals, it happens
to us too. Machine-learning is
now incorporated into a lot of
the tools that we use every day,
and a lot of our internet
experience is built off
machine-learning algorithms.
Axiom had an average 1,500 data
points, including the entire
adult population of the United
States. That was in 2012. And
that is just
one company. So, using a Chrome
extension called What Facebook
Thinks you Like, I could find
some of the ways the system has
tagged me. If you follow me on
Twitter, you know some of these
things like software developer,
and the cloud computing, like
dogs, like wine to strange, and
like kind of falls, so, mermaid,
I don't know, trench coats, I've
never read a James Paterson
book, and it got my
political proclivities wrong.
Facebook use these types of tags
to drive directed ads.
You can see that you can use
these ads to target on different
demographics, including race.
And a couple of years ago,
people could show you different
houses that you could buy
depending on these demographics,
depending on race. This is
illegal under the Software
Housing Act of 1968 but here's
the thing:  once that was
pointed out to Facebook, they
fixed it. This is a major theme
here. It is not to make software
that never fails - that's
impossible. Every
machine-learning algorithm can
have a failure, but once it does
fail, you have to course-correct
and change things. And another
problem with this that you might
have already thought about is
that you don't tell Facebook
their race. They are targeting
based on ethnic affinity which
is used by the same algorithm
that thinks I'm into mermaids.
So I'm not coming down on
Facebook in particular. This is
a problem with all
machine-learning algorithms used
by every company. So the issue
with this, and what you might
have guessed, is that everything
you're seeing is filtered, and
that filtration system can be
fallible at best, and illegal at
worst. It might not mean houses,
it can also mean that the things
and the studies that you're
seeing, and educational material
that you are seeing is based on
what you already believe, which
like that patrolling system that
we saw earlier was
self-reinforcing. I've
personally seen this. At one
point I worked for a company
that was starting to use machine
learning. They proposed an idea
to surface content based on
Demme graphics. I had happened
to read up on that issue, Mabel
that it wasn't legal, and -
mainly that it wasn't legal.
They brought it up to people
saying this could introduce
bias. Here's an important part.
I was just a regular engineer on
that project. I wasn't a data
scientist, and I wasn't a PM. I
wasn't the person shaping that
project. I was just carrying
things out. Without raising my
hand, we might have shipped that
feature to some really bad
consequences. It's not that
digitising the world is
inherently bad but the more
technology becomes embedded in
all aspect of life, it matters
whether the technology is
biased, alienating or harmful.
These tales are dark but
machine-learning offers us a lot
of amazing benefits as well, as
my brilliant co-worker said:  it
is like the risk we take every
time we get into cars or
aeroplanes. They've completely
transformed every aspect of
life, and made things possible
that wouldn't be possible
before. They're inherently
dangerous, and they can be
seriously misused. Think about
it. I wouldn't be on this stage
if it wasn't for aeroplanes, and
some of you wouldn't be here in
the same room. That's amazing.
But people have used aeroplanes
as weapons so we have a certain
respect for it. Now that I've
bummed everyone out, let's
explore some of the wonderful
applications for
machine-learning and what we can
do with it. As I mentioned, I
worked for Microsoft, and we
have a thing called cognitive
services. It is a specific API
called the emotion API. It
allows us to analyse things like
pictures and videos and see what
emotion it detects from what the
computer sees. It can be used to
make things like this which I
built in 3.js which has no
practical application except
entertaining my four-year-old
stepdaughter.
>> [Video] wow!
>> Cute.
>> Yes, there's stuff up there,
huh? Okay. Pretty magical, to
tell you the truth. What if we
put this to a more useful use. I
was mentoring a blind woman and
she mentioned to me she left out
of conversations on Twitter
because the photos didn't have
alt text. I used another
cognitive services offering, the
computer vision API which will
not only analyse a photo but
also its content like words. To
show how this works, we will
dive briefly into some of the
code. We will get the image from
the user. I'm using view of js
here. You can see here we are
using Acxios for a six call and
use the cognitive services to
analyse that image. We will do
so in a couple of different
ways. One to see what the image
contains, and one to check for
text within the image, and then
we will dynamically add the alt
text to the image. I'm building
a chrome extension is to that
blind people can use it on any
website. This application of
machine-learning can help bring
more people into the
conversation conversation, and
broaden our reach. It is not
perfect but headed in a really
good direction, where all of a
sudden, people who are left out
of the story can now be part of
it, and that is the amazing
thing, that, by being inclusive,
you're meeting business goals.
It doesn't mean you're excluding
people in the centre, it means
that you're reaching a larger
audience. There are all sorts of
ways that other people can use
machine learning in medicine
too. So one of these is Sophia
Genetics is diagnosing diseases
through DNA analysis. Another
one dear to my heart is that it
is a social cure for cancer
patients, patients enter
diagnosis and treatment so they
can be analysed. Doctors can't
just report every single patient
that they have, and they can't
read every single study, either,
so if you have all of these
people reporting what treatments
they used, whether or not they
are surviving well, then all of
a sudden this machine-learning
can pick up all of that data,
and we can become much smarter
in finding cures
for cancer.
Health map algorithms spotted an
Ebola outbreak nine days before
it happened. Nine days is an
incredible amount of lead time
for an outbreak. Outbreaks grow
exponentially. By Mark-learning
we reduced the number of those
affected from here to here.
That's amazing. You might be
saying to yourself this is all
well and good, but I'm not a
data scientist, and I don't work
with machine-learning. But
that's okay. This subject about
how technology can shape our
lives is really broad. It
doesn't necessarily have to be
machine-learning. Let's talk
about some of the things that we
as web developers can do now
today with what we already know.
We work every day on building
applications for so many
different use cases, so what if
we take some of the more generic
tools that we have and put them
to tasks where we can maybe help
save lives? So, there's a fire
house near where I live, and
they have some sufficiently
complex systems to make sure
that everything is online and
functioning. I went out to their
station, and I asked them a few
questions about how everything
works, and to see if there was
anything that I could do that I
might help. Here's what I
learned:  when the truck goes
out, it has to communicate with
a dispatcher, which will help
facilitate if they need more
water, supplies, or back-up, and
the app is really simple kind of
purposefully so because they
want everyone to be able to use
it quickly at a glance, and
there are not that many things
that they might need. What they
created was really perfect. But
I asked a few questions
including what happens if they
are all of a sudden offline?
What if they can't --
communicate. Right now, they're
hosed - get it, firemen!
Terrible!  Okay, here is our
opportunity. What I created was
a simplified version of their
app preserving the basic layout
but made use of service workers
and background to alert them
when they're offline, to cue the
messages, and, back up, to back
up, even if the browser tab is
closed. Here's what the
application looks like. If we
click on water, it registers -
the sync is registered but if we
go off Wi-Fi, it will tell them
they're offline, and I could
even close out that browser tab,
go back, and then we can turn
the Wi-Fi back on. And then the
sync is registered and what we
requested before is then sent
out. So the enquires thing --
and the request is sent out.
We're going to do that with
massive greater.online and
register a service worker when a
request is made. You can't just
add it was a method in your app.
It has to be in a different
JavaScript file. This is
important if you want to
integrate it. One thing about
this is that you're kind of
throwing it over the wall. It is
almost like communicating with
the server, so you're throwing
things at it, and it is throwing
things back. We're going to pass
in the type of event that was
triggered so we can submit or
cue what the user requested. We
will do some error-handling.
After we've activated and
installed the service worker, we
will strip out the type from the
event tag and process a fetch
when it gets to connectivity. In
that function, we will fetch the
URL which is a placeholder
server in this case and check if
the response has happened. Once
it has, we will send a message
back to the client with
post-message, so we will send
the response and the type of
resource that was requested. And
after that, we can alert the
user when it is finally
sent.
But the most important part of
the demo isn't the service
workers. It is where we started.
I went to the fire house, and I
asked them questions. And there
are a lot of times where I
wasn't sure if I could help
them. By asking questions about
what happened in any kind of use
case and any kind of scenario, I
finally found something that
they could use to help for. We
have to ask questions. We have
to ask questions in the
beginning, like the firehouse
demo. We have to ask questions
like when it is
deployed for criminal spots. We
have to keep evaluating the
systems and where they're going
and make purposeful decisions to
help people and course-correct
when we don't. I feel a lot of
tech that asks questions how to
make our lives more comfortable,
which I appreciate, I make apps
on the weekend, this is a
cocktail finder I built that
just finds me cocktails, okay?
But it seems to me that a
disproportionate amount of
projects focus inward rather
than outward, focused on serving
people with money instead of
asking people if they need help.
There are a lot of opportunity
out there to help, and you might
already have the skills to do
so. It just takes a little bit
of imagination and exploration,
and it really pay off. What I
want you to think about going
forward is this:  that I truly
believe that you have some of
the brightest minds of our
generation. As you move forward
building applications for the
web, you're building the pillars
and blocks that our society
rests on. You're crafting the
shape of our digital life. This
could mean building new
features, advocating for
accessibility, and this could be
as simple as raising your hand
when something isn't right. It
is not just your job to create
these things and do as you're
told, it is your job to ask are
we building things correctly,
building the right things, and
are we building them well for
all of the digital lives that
we've touched? Thank you.
>> Thank you very much. I
learned so much. I know the
majority of the time when we are
working on some tool, or, I
mean, products, tools, whatever,
>> Thank you very much. I
learned so much. we can't really
tell whether it is leaning
towards the more evil side of
things sometimes. Like what what
are the questions we can ask
ourselves and our team-mates to
kind of, you know, be able to
know, like, whether what we are
doing is ethical?
>> Yes, I mean, just asking the
question is the first step. For
a lot of these things, what I
mentioned before is not saying,
like, you're going to build
software the first time that
never fails, it's never going to
happen, but revaluating the
systems that you're building
them or asking the questions,
even if the answer is no, it's
probably fine but just asking
those questions upfront about
where things are going.
>> Thank you so much. That was
our last talk!
[Cheering and Applause]. Oh, my
God. I can't believe it's almost
over. I found my suit. I think
they saw that Sean - they saw
that Sean told me I could tweet
him, and he would help me, and
so I guess they, like, I can
help her, you know, make faster
applications.
I'm like cool. I'm good!  So.
Yes.
>> That makes total sense.
>> Anyway, so we have our panel
coming up, and we're going to be
talking up here on stage, and
answering some of your questions
that you asked, some of the
panellists. It is still up
online, so, if you go to
slido.com and then enter jsconf
as the event code. You can still
ask questions and vote on
questions that you care about
that we
can ask.
>> Yeah. Great.
>> I think we're going to take a
quick break to set up. Five
minutes. We can get people up
here on the stage.
>> Don't stray too far. Come
back in five minutes!
[Applause].
>> That was very sudden. We were
breathe,common and breathing. We
are human, we so it's just a
very thing to talk
are about!   Who introduce. Hi!
we
>> Should
>> I've likeever Not these
people!  them - seen
times ten has of!  Twitter, do
both famous on we talk, People
thanself-introduction followers
combined.could quick who a you
domicrophone, The again.  at I'm
Dan. yes.
>> I work [inaudible].
manager  programme Sean a  I'm
Larkin,
>> and slido, open up at
Microsoft.
>> We audience questions, so we
were accepting
>> yes.
tradition Justlist. is down this
apparently, this is   First
people have question going to
Iceland, it  question Icelandic
is like a foreigners. in all a
go ask that like you How do to
why. can why. You them don't
>> I know ask
Iceland the given  just have I I
haven't because seen much of I
yet and talk,Iceland?
[Inaudible].[inaudible].  So
watch. I'm to I'm going look  So
forward prettyquite up  to.
like grew  feels like So Sea, I
for
>> me, it the North a bit home.
close tocountries.  to
Scandinavian beingpretty close
nice is Yes, it
>>least here. Iceland's
typically   at I'm beer, like
awesome.  to So We story.
[Cheering]. long think it and it
allergic a is - I American
problem, beer, is
>> European nocan beer, that's
drink more Icelandic so really
one so I great beer.
>> countryare can enjoy the hope
locals  Great, I all the
high-- you  satisfied!  all Now,
werehigh-performing yeah?
question you Our alltips are for
being   people. What  do you
productive? havenext
>> You know. don't really I
you [Laughter].  Sorry, pass if
can
>>
want.  want.
>> [Inaudible].
>> Sounds like you're doing
David AllenGTD in the next
actual item. That's something I
just subscribed to, or
proscribed to. Like, when you
have something you need to
accomplish, just write down the
next actionable thing that you
can do, and you constantly
Whittall away at it until you've
completed something. And the
list when I'm at home, and the
list when I'm in my email, like
the list when I'm on Twitter
doing DMs. But then also, I
would say, like, there's another
part of that GTD method which is
like do defer or delegate. If
it's not your top priority, I
mean, if you can do it in less
than two minutes, just do it. If
you can't, defer it to when it
is appropriate, and if, like,
whether people like to hear it
if it is not worth their time,
then delegate to somebody else
who is more suited for it.
Otherwise, like ask people for
help. So people like ask how do
you do things all the time. I'm
usually drowning in people and
calling up for help. We really
rely on other people around us
in the community to help us get
things done for webpack.
>> I don't feel like I have a
great answer to this question.
Like I have something that is
like, trying to understand
things, like those things that
like together, really nicely.
And just like I care a lot about
what I do. I mean, that sounds
very, very generic, but it is
true, and like that's why I
can't keep doing - I can keep
doing node for such a long time.
I've never worked on a project
for more than a year or
anything, and it's like -
yes.
>> Yes, I just wanted to add,
I've got [inaudible]. I have had
a lot of help. Like, do the
actions design work for them,
I've got [inaudible]. I have had
a lot of help. Like,
so, ...
>> And the other thing that
[inaudible]. But I just used to
not being anxious for these
the found with list, to-do
getting and multiple you
overwhelmed emails notes,by that
know, sometimes,  the amount of
stuff youknow, in likeyou're
doing, and,  it gets lost there
and lists, Is that. all you
with youthe away that deal this
in  systems that
my  mean,assistance,  I do?
It's like,
huge, a like having
>>like,
not being scared ...   works to
read. It
everything in usuallypretty
well. It's like ... I I if
something usually,me it, really
like, badmean,  care of happens
I pings  zero feels and somebody
take inbox thedon't the that,
getting
>> about that. Yes, good. So,
really I've archiveto I no there
got details,  a try and, if are
it. If actionable search at or
three  instantlycan two  by I
need to for only let it, like,
then you will most glance   but
I at there, the end ofmy work
sit day, them yes. archive
emails them, to foreven then I
tryanyway. I have created  tasks
>> Next Awesome.
question? What do guessingdon't
that - I'm you see the question
are   what  like, that you means
good applications some common a
problems see in JavaScript
currently havesolution
to?
>>
maybe to?
>> [Inaudible].
>> [Inaudible]. I think
describedsame Dan  what  that
things having ...
>> In the same what used, a
actually library using
understanding understanding or a
if you're can bearound component
you   so,  methodology around
education the code leverage,
think you what and I like is,
identify,or something, of this
how you to type about module I
guess howcould go you know,
like,just  and how package or
details say alike, this health,
understanding those  this seeing
Is What often. BSM? depend is
contributed inlibraries written
this  this  other does whator
on.just trying
Or does havedependencies? about
Things that you  somethingmay
not think you're another. to
write long-standing but a impact
if you add a versus feature,
could havepull in libraryreally
the plug wrong also  to  I
>> is I'm going mything again,
but think it works hard to that
write thedirectly. I I code that
write  the hope some of help
features used in demo  us with
butasynchronousspecifically
questions is  that. We is
generaler this one more
specific. It have server-site
with rendering you work for Dan.
Will in?  the API demonstrated
>>future have currently not
rendering. We do  tohave
server-side  howimplementation
for yes, weimplementingneed
about  In theory, findcommunity
but will we will  hopefully,
theories we're  make andthis
work actually we probably later
so some help from thegoing for
details that,  to post some help
people who can
toask:  your us.  The next
question I want  what isopinion
unpopular
>>front-end and
dev? it's  that opinion is My
unpopularwebsites.  fast complex
ship bit not to and little
>> going to process It just
takes a  it's of to treating
citizen, andperformance like a
an  course, first-class
difficult tackle so, of andI be
try  project, existing but to
evangelise trying make always
heavily thingsperformance and
muchJavaScript likepart of   how
how muchsomethingCSS you're
projects, shipping,  as culture
shipping, just as the of that
and itcitizen. If  the
first-classsacrificing  you
treated  of you come back
yourself out just theunless
you'retechnologies, you're  dig
you're to,  just using be then
right almost and then if going
to feature a anda hole, it as
time, anything foryou treat
standard that is a  Soifmean,
that  down easy. but  hard, it
is  thenyou like, of boiling it
any I is kind I know, happy me
into easy I'm concepts, ask you
understand the andand you can as
long time, as  to spendpossible
but, this, explaining opinion. I
unpopular don't like an yes.
>> Okay,
CSS and JS asconcept!   I  like,
a
[Applause].  mean, [Laughter].
I lot ahaven'tand, done a for
while, might like, it I
separation learned so think
front-end I  years agoit is
idea, maybe nicejust becoding
me. sort, of someopinions!   all
not unpopular that ... .  two
>> I
>> have better! opinion
>> Theis more unpopular the
things The first  think feel to
that we I thiscrazy camp"people
here in  or, "Everybody's don't
have in that's the same got way.
this think over  to  just are
like, "Everybody do  have I
differentbuilding it and  all
way." for  teams audiences
because webig and we'redifferent
sized different just  use cases,
I forlittle really different
reasons. we need think that the
internet web  is in our  a down
some put tent, and flexible to
be a and bit more thinking,
those arguments. But are fine
too. My second opinion, going
which is sure, yes, probably
you're like, going be,
everyone'sunpopular to to  say
is SVG that,underutilised  and
awesome for the on web!
Especially worked for lead
contracts benefits. I'vefrom ten
performancewheregraphics and
their consulting   things.
optimising  I took and one
optimising the time SVG seconds
performance down to things to
second by changing over and SVG
Use when learnwould it!   like,
>> I know -is unpopular, I
peoplewould one  this if for
don't  know don't   ask
So I here andis a unpopular. say
opinion, here on there  Twitter,
think my really unpopular Ioften
it's not butcommunity of be it,
synthetic lot  focus in the on
benchmarks, that doesn't load
this describe that synthetic
what a very of an and like table
a shows comparison focus more on
actual anddifferent benchmarks
implementations with real-world
betteras a create  scenarios,
think  should like. I and
application we looks community,
consider,
then,timetiny  application  that
if a your can optimisetwo-times
and  slice of it you forever
makethelayers is  more
performant, if  tiny actual
problemactually  all the doesn't
that  optimising that you have,
real
like,slice you're the optimise
-- you need - affect We need
need toapplication time.whole
tiny we   we one have -to
optimisations on the just  not
apply  all on whole - and and
programmes, like layers, feel
>>Dan's has layer. I slowly
just  into opinions like -   it
feel He unpopular makes turn I
thatpopular just opinions.
opinion.  energy that popular
into a my
>> Then I change mind!
[Laughter].
>>
So, what excited about in  you
mostthe most - are what
is JavaScript
to over ecosystem?  for each I
want scoot here!
>> of
[Laughter].
>> [Laughter] joke! a That's
you doesn't build the same I
just way. think
[Laughter].  I React is not bad!
your said
most single the that single
It's likeexciting
>> thing supported thing. Is
exciting absolute  be it - most
excitingfor be really  not to
without - the  is Node That will
Node in 6can everybody thenany
assembly more. Like, so it. many
justsingle different web to me
because  we usefeatures use can
like, youand that,  different
become available type so much of
have  Node. Wecoding done on be
a  6 as  can Nodesecond-class to
treat a assembly as whole Web is
library. wereto our citizen if
we  pull it into going to with
>> going to go just be crazy.
I'm not is actually has the not
Node. It MPM  language that,
remotely.incredibly  other own
like stuff  like public.
registry, no your so anything
make like Yes,  just to Just
easythat.
for questions   So many
>> Dan.
>> audience
Crowd favourite!   He's an
favourite.  feel generic
>> I a Let's one. see. like but
I I upvoted too not foundthat
it's the
>> something Luke, "Can you like
identify from
>> question. Go says for it.
It made that you career feel
most your a moment in joyful?"
happen,
I all worst that  the follow our
breaking, things down,  builds
especially of I like our in is
career, change like and
production good that, feel like
this weis a
always pace. web working think
So app  Yeah. was
>> web a Iwebpack was - on it
JS to an, andI from  I think it
a and  found page called "hot
was converting I motor
Iabout in 2014, was.
docs, webpack the old I
replacement" on so asked webpack
API me, it on docs none of to
the Slack and where made sense
just described functions what
really itandis explanation, with
good and exactly that replied
reallycould I I  a React wow.
so I was withdeclarative, so
thinking, like  combinebecause
it thathave is   maybe is React
could in changes and see I
fascinated components  edit my
an soreal update,maybe was of
thought   time, and prototype I
I can a bythis. this. think I
until make 6 stayed   I I itam
was kind am, 6  in I Alchemy at
to and  and finally, working it,
of video ofwho  video to time
and followers at therecord a 50
posted the Twitter, I my had
were felt that It Christopher
friends. tweeted video.   going
to isgood!  aboutbut,
>> I feel one, like thiswas be
a weird   itactually, thinking I
like, actually when what I'm
understood my it's in like,
right now, much completely mind,
happeninglike, pretty  was a
what actually the call to
executes actual the main when a
programmes like just lino isand
programme. It from  whatever
every step on, of going function
muchthere are supposed to run,
is like so just pretty  is
amazing to to like it and
understand.  look at
most a to
>> I think the got to goexciting
for me, ever my  for yes, I  in
- the time time  a atcareer was
ever spoke first wasMGConf and I
so I conferencethe first was
time don't conference even
feeling did  Itechnology or  but
the remember if how  really well
not, understand people clap of
isthe it
it having  andunsensationalably
was -  when and kind eye for you
good their works, of so sparkle
in feels
addicting,empower,  to
insatiaiating be able topeople
have the it meant of  about that
or kind addicting. Kind other be
passionate same things you
moments love.  really  that
been
>> haven't most significant very
I actually they think probably
been of the like for me have
quiet,where,been, like, a
forgetting moment   what hours,
and you know, Eureka for 12 eat
aprobablytime,  like happened
and working that'sstuff, having
feel mode,  to pee but flow I
and just great that me because
when  the happiest.I'm in  like
So noone that are when I'm  that
thethis,morerecordable  that
moments like   for say something
was so I to would that of been
comes had I a lot mind a was
like making for career-enhancing
andconference wasanything, to
long quietly   I work  really
time, this showed nobody knew
whotonne or and like I spoke at
where I a  see day.
Because people and all of a that
of demos,analytics sudden that
kind could from   oflikesaw my
you that  the went and went on
to websitewas that this  and
been Ireally goodgoing to I've
that because work, stuff was a
people  probably the  feeling,
bass this that like finally But
are say, look at forever. would
makingbut yeah, I  been  one,
ones have most career-enhancing
the happiest
next question was specifically
for Anna but could be for
everyone as well. Anna, what is
a good entry-level way to get
involvedprivate. The with the
Node project. It seems everyone
here is active with the
different open-source project,
so I think generally, what's a
good entry-level way to get
involved with an
open-source project?
>> You can have my
mic. It's like -
>> It is like, for Node
specifically, there's this
awesome website, it's called
nodetodo.org. I'm so glad he is
around Node, and he maintains a
list of good first contributions
for
Node. And yeah, if you're
interested doing that, that's a
really good starting point. You
can also like try to talk to me
and I will find something for
you. And yes, you might want to
like, if you have something that
you're especially interesting in
in Node, that might be a good
thing to do, just message me,
otherwise go to nodetodo.org.
>> I should say figure out what
drives you and what gets you out
of bed every day if you want to
contribute to something? Take
that skill and apply it to the
project if it is applicable.
Most times, it is going to be.
When I started contributing to
webpack or even joined the core
team, I had one commit to the
project, and that's it. And I
had zero following on Twitter,
so all I would do is go on
Twitter, and search webpack. And
I responded to every single
tweet. That's it. Like I
literally did that, because, at
the time, I had worked in
technical support, and I worked
with people, and so it is an
easy way for me to provide value
that's totally in my wheel-house
before speaking, doing
documentation, before any of it.
Usually, like when people ask me
this question, I usually end up
losing them to a different
project like Babel or React
because they're like I like
working on V-dom instead. I
always say understand what you
love to work on. That to me is
what open source is about, that
you are working on things that
really drive you, and then
making the world better because
everybody else depends
on it.
Then also to quote Dan Abramov
on Twitter, another advice is
like code seems intimidating,
just start at the most familiar
place, and then branch out. I
think that is like pseudo
quoting!  Start somewhere where
you can understand and read and
go further.
>> I still don't understand like
50 per cent of code in
React!  I would say that, like,
since I work in the Reacted
team, I should say something
about React, and I would say
that maybe React itself is not
the most easily accessible
project to contribute to because
there is like, it is even hard
for us to contribute to it just
because it is so, like, large
and complex in terms of what it
needs to do and how you need to
think about all those features
behaving well together. And
we're trying to improve the
documentation but it is pretty
hard. But I think there is an
ecosystem, and like the way I
think one of the first
contributions that I did before
I was on the React teem, I -
team, I was working on a
project like a web app, and I
needed routing, and I saw this
project called React Router but
the problem was it didn't
support, so when it switched
between different pages, I think
it would always crawl to the top
-
scroll to the top, but I had an
interface where I had tabs
inside my app and I didn't want
them switching tabs to scroll to
the top. I sent
a VR to implement this
behaviour, and they've since
removed that code and made it
work differently. I think it is
important as you don't have to
come to the open source with the
mind set of where can I start
contributing?
You can build your own stuff
that you need for your app but
have this mind set that this
application code, it's not
something that is packaged and
given to you, and you can't
tweak it. It is just code
reading by other people. It has
hacks, it is not super fast,
maybe didn't spend optimising
it. It might lack important
features, and, if you come with
this mind set of this code could
as well have been written by me,
then you can see, here's how I
can improve it. Here is the
thing that I need for my app.
Just try to add it,
and it is often very small
things that are valuable. Maybe
that helps.
>> I think there are really good
ideas in here. There's a couple
of small things like a lot of
GitHub repos have helped wanted,
good first-issue labels. You can
definitely explore those. There
are other ways to contribute
too, like speakers need people
to practise with, if you know
somebody else that is giving a
first-time talk, or you can help
mentor them in that way, or you
can mentor people doing peer
programming. It doesn't
necessarily have to be your
first commit or something like
that. If you're interesting in
doing first commit, I think
reading through the issues and
getting a sense of where things
are most valuable, reading
before committing is really
helpful because then you kind of
can see like what is going on in
whole project, what people are
most focusing on, what people
are having a hard time with.
Taking some information in
before adding things, and I
guess the last thing I would say
is don't have your first commit
be huge. Like, it is really hard
to get a commit in that is
gigantic because maybe you have
a piece of it that is great and
some other part, they can't use
it, and you've got to have a
million comments back and forth
on your PR. The first time you
commit something, maybe pick a
small thing that you can work
on, more likely to get it.
>> I also just realised that
another very helpful - Sarah put
it, you don't have to make
commits your first contribution.
I think what a lot of projects
really need, and that includes
React, is just somebody helping
people out and the issues. For
example, I - so, when I started
working with JavaScript, I have
a file, so the first things that
I try to do was just, I was
reading questions that people
would post, and I tried to
answer them, even though I don't
really know the things, so I
would research that question for
them, and try to figure it out,
and, if I have after solution, I
would post it. That really
helped my learning. I think you
can do the same with any
projects you care about. You can
go to the section, see someone
posted the bug, try to reproduce
it, debug, maybe suggest you use
this thing wrong, or maybe
there's an actual bug and you
could add more details from
somebody somebody from the team
to help fix that bug.
>> One more weird anecdote story
off of that which is really
cool. There is a guy that works
with me who is like LinusBorg on
GitHub, and he actually isn't a
programmer for everyday life, he
does a completely different job,
and he's got a hobby of
contributing to open source, and
he's on the core team. The way
he started was he went through,
and he read a bunch of view
code, and then started answering
forum questions, and he did that
for a really long time until we
were like, "Why aren't you on
the core team?"  He's built
libraries and things like that,
but I think that's such a great
example and hopefully he's on
the stage telling the story,
because I think that's such a
cool thing that you can kind of
start off answering questions
and then eventually know the
system so well that you're a
core contributor.
>> A lot of really good ideas
there. I hope to see more people
after this conference, go home -
not tonight, because a party
tonight. Go home, and make at
least one contribution to one
open-source project. That would
be great. I think we should wrap
it up. Yeah. Any last words
of advice?
>> If I'm allowed to criticise
GitHub a little bit, I think it
would be great - so one of the
people contributions to
open-source is selfish, which is
fine. If people want to show off
as contributors and have that in
their profile, but as far as I
know, even if you spend two
years responding to issues and
helping people, you still don't
show up as a contributor on that
project, so if GitHub could
change that, that would be
really great.
>> Also, if GitHub, if you're
listening!
>> We have at least two GitHub
employees here!  I would really
love a pay-to-support
button.
For webpack and things - I do
support webpack and other
projects but I would love to buy
someone a coffee or do something
really quick to help support
people, so, that would be really
awesome.
>> There are egg balls on their
product it'll. She wrote a paper
about open-source funding, and
that's how she ended up at
GitHub. She's on their product
team now. That could be a thing
in the future.
>> Are you listening Nadia? Yes.
Final remarks. I would say - I
said it in my talk, and, like,
I'm trying to destroy the idea
of JavaScript fatigue. I know we
have everyday jobs and we need
to get them done, but it's
really important that we
understand and embrace change,
especially with JavaScript. This
language changes so much. And
so, we do it at Microsoft, it is
part of our growth mind set.
Understanding and adapting to
different changes makes you more
dynamic as a programmer, or just
a human being in general. We're
not saying you have to use the
latest technologies but embrace
what they are, and take five
minutes out of your day to
understand what they are, what
they do, and what they
accomplish. Look at the
patterns, and how they can be
used in the things that you do
every day. That way, your
everyday work doesn't feel
frustrated. Embracing the
JavaScript Renaissance is fun,
but struggling with JavaScript
fatigue, nobody wants to do
that. I think that it is really
important that you change the
mind set. If I were to ask
anything of you all, it's to
consider trying it. If it
doesn't work, tell me I'm wrong
on Twitter and show me this
screen capture. Yeah.
>> So I think I have two notes.
One is something I talked about
at this conference was, if you
think that some software product
could do something better, that
you're using like Node, or
webpack or anything, and you
find a way to work around that,
that's cool, but maybe file an
issue. Because, like, if you're
running into that problem like
100 other people will at least,
and you have a chance to make
their lives easier. Take that,
and the other thing is it's like
a lot of these questions that
were kind of like how to be
successful in open scores. Or at
least some of them were, and one
of the things that helps me a
lot is doing completely
different stuff, like that has
nothing to do with coding at
all. Like, your brain needs that
- you can't work without that.
It's take a lot of time to do
different stuff.
>> Awesome, thank you so much to
Dan, Sarah,
Sean, and Anna. And thank you so
everyone on
this panel. That was a great
discussion. I'm sure we could
have heard more questions and
answers. I've learned a lot from
all of
you combined.
>> Don't cry. Stop it!
>> And also, thank you to the
organisers. I think we should
wrap up and get to the closing,
and, yes. Thank you. Thank
you so much. [Applause].
still We  closing don't leave
have the
remarks.
>> We've come to the end of our
two-day event. It's been super,
wonderful. Who enjoyed the
whole thing?
[Cheering and Applause].
I just want to take my time to
thank all the organisers for
doing all of this. They've
worked so hard. They behind the
scenes. Everything is running so
smoothly up here, but like
sometimes, they're dealing with
so much stuff, I just want to
thank them and give them a round
of applause because they've been
so amazing. [Applause].
So, yeah, we've come to the end.
And it's, I mean, really sad.
>> Sad face.
>> But we're not going to let
this get
to us. We are here for jokes.
Those who can't see, it says
roses are red, violets are blue,
unexpected line, unexpected
basket on line
32.
And to those who can see it,
yes, I programme in Java, I've
been stuck at this enterprise
job for the last five years, I'm
slowly deteriorating, this isn't
a meme, it is a legitimate call
for help!  It's cut off. But
there's another one. Anyway,
we've really enjoyed this, and
what do you think of it?
>> It's been wonderful.
>> Best time ever.
>> I feel like we feel like John
Snow on that one. It was really
fun who made that photobooth.
>> The helmets were way too big
for my head.
>> It was heavy. It didn't fit
my head as well. Iceland is so
great but I decided to change my
name. I want it more Icelandic
sounding.
>> So my dad's name is
Orlando.
>> So I think I'm technically
Orlando's daughter, so that is
my name now!
>> Is it even approved by the
naming committee? I think they
have strict rules.
>> The website of the list of
approved names by the Icelandic
naming committee. I picked the
ones that were closely, very
similar to my name. So I think
that's how is works out.
>> I don't know if you realised
that people here are very tall,
and we're
not tall. I'm 1 centimetres 58
on a good day depending on
humidity. I don't know, I don't
think we will be accepted as
Icelandic.
>> I think that's part of their
citizenship test:  how tall are
you? Are you at least 170. No,
I'm not!  So, I
just want to post our Twitter
again, because I want to be
Twitter famous like Dan but also
keep in touch with everyone,
because I enjoyed my
interactions with everyone so
far, and I have had really good
conversations with a lot of you.
It's been really great. Follow
me and Vanessa on Twitter, and
follow these conversations and
talking about JavaScript, and
you can also follow my memes. I
post a lot of really, I mean,
dumb shit sometimes. So let's
talk about the party tonight.
We're going to Bazaar.
There are buses scheduled from
5.45 to 11 from the Marina and
here, so get ready to party. I
heard that there is a karaoke,
so I bet, like, 20 bucks
someone's going to sing, "Don't
stop believing".
Someone's going to do that.
>> For sure.
>> Mr Bright Side, Wonder Wall.
All of
that!  I want to promote again
how Canadian we are!  So
sorry!
>> Saturday.
>> We do have a trip on Saturday
which is great because we get to
see Iceland. We're driving down
to the south coast, it will be
from 10. Is that six now? I
don't know how to read time. And
it is cut off over here. Yes,
there's more info on the
website. So check it out. And,
apparently, there's been some
cancellations, so there will be
a waiting list opening it up at
the website. So, you can sign up
for that if you don't already
have a ticket, and then we're
also going to the Blue Lagoon
for a farewell brunch, and this
is information. I'm really
excited. It's been on my bucket
list for the longest time. Yes,
that's us. I'm glad that most
people use the nose ring and
arrest ring to tell me and
Vanessa apart. Nose ring
Florida, ear
Rick, Vanessa. It works out.
Thanks very much to everyone.
>> You all have been a wonderful
audience, and so a round of
applause for all of you.
>> And I'm going to call on the
organisers to come up on stage
because I think they want to say
something as well.
>> We really appreciate you
flying in to be the Masters of
the Ceremony. A big thank you to
you both. Give them a round of
applause for an awesome
something as well.
>> We really appreciate you
flying in to be the Masters of
job.
[Cheering and Applause]. Yes,
the party tonight. It is not
over yet. It is just like a sore
moment, tears are starting to
flow out. But we still have two
more days, and one night, so we
are technically halfway through,
depending on how you look at it.
But, yes, we will have all of
the info on the website. Contact
us on Slack. We want to end like
we end everything at JSConf with
a big family photo. I want to
get all the organisers to the
stage to echo what they said
without tooting my own horn.
Epic job by these people.
Really. Give them a round of
applause. [Applause].
And, yes, with that being said,
I want to invite all of you to
the stage.
We will have to move some of the
tables a bit And, yes, away. We
are probably 250 or 300 people
still in the audience, so it's
going to take an effort to put
this all on the stage. The photo
will be epic. So, thank you all
for coming. Join us on the
stage, and enjoy
the rest of JSConf Iceland!
Cheers!